[Music]
foreign
stop
[Music]
three two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
two one here we go
[Music]
thank you
come on
no I thought I lost that time I just
myself hello everyone this is your daily
dose of Internet this is Criminal oh
that was criminal I win
I won
[Music]
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm too good at this game I'm gonna win
this thing oh baby and then this
is always the next move oh he
surrendered I knew it guys we're
geniuses
ready they have this chest rabbit that's
just terrible
[Music]
welcome back everyone to pogchamps five
this is your favorite Creator chess
tournament and if it isn't yet well
hopefully it will be by the time it's
over I'm Levy Rosman I'm joining you for
the third time and with me for the first
time in her commentary debut on
pogchamps is well not pot Champs but
James 5 is Alexandra Bose Alexandra how
are you welcome to podcast five I was so
excited to be here
pogchamps one was definitely one of the
most memorable things in my streaming
career so the fact that it's made it
this far and creators in the audience is
still excited it's it's a dream
yeah listen uh the the the drama the the
blunders the brilliancies like all of
that has stayed the the story arcs of
all the players none of that has changed
from pogchamps one but uh we have had
some incredible chess we had we had a
day of tense matches yesterday all went
to tie breaks every day we're building a
new story uh and we will continue uh
building a cool story today with all of
the matches that we have going on let's
just remind everybody for hopefully the
last time maybe the penultimate time if
you haven't watched yet uh what POG
Champs 5 is all about it's four groups
of four players that could be tough for
some of us but that's 16 players in
total they all play wow yeah that I
actually have it on a piece of paper I
don't even have to calculate it um and
uh they all have to play each other and
So based on the scoring of the groups
the top two move on to a Champions
bracket the bottom to go to a
consolation and for the first time ever
there will be a live Final in Los
Angeles on August the 18th to determine
the winner of POG Champs five uh and uh
both of your hosts today will be there
uh but only if my flight doesn't get
canceled so I'm looking forward to it
that's pretty exciting stuff
yeah I mean we've never had this happen
before with creators in chess for a
chess.com event we did have it with
official chess players nobody's gonna
remember this but let me know in the
chat if you remember when we were doing
the PCL finals and we thought it was so
Grand groundbreaking and here we are
today this is gonna be awesome yeah I'm
really really looking forward to it
let's remind everybody of our groups and
what's been going on uh all the way from
the top left we have Sea Dog VA the
number one ranked player in the
tournament with five points out of six
leading the pack although yesterday he
was slowed down and nearly defeated by
the mysterious Jarvis Johnson superhero
if you will uh meanwhile we've got the
group of death Group B uh with Gastly up
top still two wins in two matches Group
C just beginning to get underway Tyler
won with three points uh the C and D are
lagging a little bit but we're gonna get
them all cut up uh D just hasn't even
played at all but uh Alexandra when you
look at these groups uh does anybody
stick out to you
so one of the people who I think is a
dark horse and we're gonna see him
playing today which is why bringing up
is I did a thing he hasn't been playing
chess for that long but he seems to be
picking up the fundamentals extremely
quickly what about you
uh he also looks like Theo James which I
I said before we even went live and
that's from that's from White Lotus
season two uh great show and reminded me
immediately so I'm I'm looking forward
to that matchup also uh but yeah for me
it's Group B uh in every World Cup for
football there's a group of death where
all four teams can beat each other in
group b it seems like anybody can beat
anybody and today we do have a groupie
matchup but before I even get into
specifics right now let's throw the
matchups on the screen of what's coming
up today uh we're gonna start off in
group a which is Frank vs psychuno Frank
did have a nice win uh versus Jarvis and
we'll show you a little clip of that
later saikuno almost uh got one off of
Sea Dog but obviously he was the
underdog he did succumb uh but yeah this
matchup uh daily dose of Internet versus
sapnap the boat test sisters know both
of these players well so are you looking
forward to that matchup
I am I'm excited to see them I mean
sapnap is a little bit annoying he's
always coming in our chat and spamming
but no jokes aside uh they're both
friends sapnap does seem to have more
experience he's played in more things
like this but daily dose is one of the
most eager people to get into pogchamp
so hopefully that enthusiasm can make up
for his uh slightly less experience
yeah listen daily dose played a
fantastic match uh last time versus
Gastly uh and of course we will have our
our main event of the evening uh that
will be I did a thing listen who was
just heavily promoted by my co-host
versus Papa Plata who we've kind of like
not really addressed but he he's an OG I
mean he played in one of the original
pot Champs in fact like the first one
unless I'm going insane I might yeah he
was definitely in the first one okay so
there you go right he's representing
Germany uh when we announce the players
uh for for uh POG Champs five there was
some complaints from sardosh uh and some
you know the French audience that uh we
did not bring a French streamer this
time we don't make those decisions we'd
love to represent everybody but Germany
is on the map uh and that that is
definitely a very very exciting one uh
which of the matchups today are we most
keen on I mean I'm gonna say that I'm
gonna steal the answer first I'm gonna
say daily dose versus sapnap just
because Group B is so fascinating to me
but you could you know you could echo my
sentiments no I love it you're here for
the bloodlust I like seeing it when it's
a little bit closer I'm I'm also hoping
that saikuno might make a little bit of
a comeback although I see that our chat
has been overtaken by Frank fans
um but it's always nice to see it come
back
yeah it's tough to say in this POG
Champs who who is like the crowd
favorite I've seen a ton of Frank stuff
and and the twitch chat just gets really
really really cool like quick
everybody's spamming their you know
wearing their emotions on the on their
sleeve especially when the tick tock and
YouTube audiences kind of converge right
here but we've also seen a lot of big
Tonka uh so we've seen a lot of tyler1
support uh we've seen we've seen a lot
of people
um and here we see a little reel of
Frank screaming uh after his victory
over Jarvis
and the I I don't know how he doesn't
cause himself to have a heart attack but
he's a chest sensation over 60 million
views on YouTube I I don't even know how
many he has on tick tock tick tock
analytics are a little bit tough to pull
out but it's it's got to be close to
that a self-described future Grand
Master and he's played over a thousand
games on chess.com which is a lot but
other players in the event have have
played more and today he's wearing black
he was wearing white the other day is
this symbolic is this like a is there a
favorite color that you would wear to
tournaments like were you superstitious
you think he's superstitious
I wish I wasn't superstitious uh but my
dad once told me that if I ever walk
around the house with one sock someone
in my family will die and I accidentally
did that one day I'm not gonna finish
the sentence nobody died but my dad was
very upset so I've been superstitious
ever since and at tournaments if I win I
would just keep wearing the same thing
when I was a kid but now I've grown and
evolved so that's that's a good thing
what about yourself literally you just
unlocked the core memory my my my
grandparents used to tell me if I wore
black socks or black underwear I was
like hiding something anyway that just
like blew my mind I I like did not
remember that and now I did speaking of
his opponent though of Frank and wearing
black we've got saikuno who's wearing
green and a star there uh we we all know
saikuno makes a lot of content streams
so many games is involved with so many
different collabs and streamers he's uh
in some of the biggest uh friendship
circles when it comes to streaming he's
got nearly 3 million subscribers on
YouTube uh a streamer of the Year
overall nominee which is a big deal
because there's only four of them uh and
uh yeah I mean we're we're looking to
see if he can build on his strong result
in his match versus uh Sea Dog where he
was 104 or something but the game review
said he was 700 so that's always nice
right when game review gives you a 600
Point bonus yeah no saikunos chess.com
rating is definitely not accurate he
played in one of our previous uh chess
events that we threw and he completely
surprised me because I never saw him
practice and I didn't know what his
level was and he just came and he
performed pretty solidly and you can't
judge him based off going up against the
top seeds so yeah it could happen it's
true and I've already been seeing some
fan Rumblings like oh I don't trust him
I think he has an account and he plays
on that account he just shows up and you
know like he's it's called gamesmanship
I'm like really
like is is HE capable of that is that a
thing in the streamer world you're more
connected to I feel like more variety
gaming is that what people do they just
pretend to be bad and then they actually
are secretly grinding because that seems
deranged so I'm not going to listen to
your audience if somebody is doing that
I could see saikuno he is very smart and
very good at a lot of games so I can
imagine him doing anything to get an
edge and honestly I would do it if I was
in his shoes yeah I mean right it's
better somebody thinks you're 104 but
you're actually an 800 you're just like
I don't know what I'm doing I won by
accident uh we see uh I think we're
gonna pull Frank up for a little for a
little bit couple of minutes here uh
we're gonna our match time is delayed by
about five minutes uh players are just
getting in their seats we gotta crop
them pogchamps is a big big production
Frank is
um I don't know what he's doing but
let's unmute him and and let's not even
hypothesize let's
guys
many dilemmas
oh goodness me goodness gracious me
okay composure Frank composure don't let
the water win I win I win the water
loses and I climb Mount Everest one day
you know I do want to climb Mount
Everest one day because if you think
about it
um very few people wait no actually no
no because there's a lot of oh yeah you
know what actually I don't want to climb
out nervous because it's very tall and
cold but you know what I do like the
cold weather more than the warm weather
oh do I like oh do I like warm weather
more than cold weather or cold weather
than warm weather I don't know what's
better see guys this is what I've been
saying weather is determined by the
season
and the festivals in that season if that
makes sense so you're gonna think about
it you're gonna think well you're on
about Frank what are you on about summer
Summer's good but there's not much going
on in the summer like it's just it's
just a normal holiday you're like oh
it's summer oh I'm gonna go out my
friends I'm gonna do stuff but there's
not a lot going on but in winter winter
you've got you've got Christmas don't
you and in Christmas yeah if you think
about it Christmas there's a lot going
on at Christmas you've got like Santa
Clauses he's coming he's eating is he in
his biscuits he's having a good day he's
doing well for himself and then
um then while Santa's well and you've
got Santa eating the biscuits being
summer here you're just going out and if
you don't have many friends in summer
it's not that fun is it but if you have
a oh this is the thing see winter and
summer they're like the big dogs of the
seasons aren't they they're contesting
each other they're against each other oh
but the thing is I would say I'm more
partial to winter but then am I biased
because I live in England
do the countries help you decide which
season you like better or oh oh this is
a difficult play to
them but then okay I feel like I just
experienced ADHD it's spring quite good
as well oh it's it's still going it's a
sorry Autumn winter and summer those are
the those are the Four Seasons right you
see awesome
I'm sorry am I supposed to speak after
that another thing I will say will ever
come close I why are we commentating
just get just leave him on the screen
the whole time no he he is content Frank
trying to be a grand master trying to be
a philosopher
a man of many talents what can we say
what what did he say what was the okay
let's just remind everybody what what
he's playing uh you know because when
you think about it like the summer and
winter holiday seasons all have to do
with the holidays of that season uh and
so pogchamps has to do with a best of
two rapid games and uh what that means
is that if the score is one and a half
to half or two to zero that person wins
in the rapid section of the match and
they get the full three points that they
are playing for uh but sometimes it's
one to one and
you have to play a tie break and we had
two tie breaks yesterday but we're not
going to explain the rules to you
because it's it will just explain them
to you when it when and if we we have to
so uh
thank God we're gonna get some games
because I was not prepared for more
rants about I'm not exactly sure what
the seasons the weather but it's just
fun to see Frank going on while cycuno
is so poised patiently waiting
um they're both wearing black they both
got a similar haircut but they're Polar
Opposites and the games have begun okay
let's get started ah the games have
begun and we have E4 we have E5 and we
have a knight going to the F3 Square
targeting this saikuno played Knight to
F6 against Sea Dog I don't know if
that's because he likes that opening or
okay Frank is now going to play this
move and try to play for a fried liver
he loves himself some fried liver
but he's not going to be able to do it
if the bishop comes to C5 but we'll see
what saikuno does well it's good to see
that saikuno switched up his openings it
seems like maybe he had played Knight F6
by accident
yeah or you know maybe this time he's
just playing uh he's looking to play a
C3 Knight F6 Gucci piano you know
castles all right
move stop temperatures I mean sapnap
because they're both their username
start with s I mean it's basically the
same thing uh saikuno uh opting for an
Italian in this game and Frank is
castling wow this is excellent stuff
from psychuno I I I don't I don't trust
the 159 I mean no it is totally
inaccurate and now saikuno doesn't have
to worry about dealing against the
forever if Knight G5 comes in he can
just Castle his seven Pawn is safe and
even though the fried liver isn't
accurate it's actually very terrifying
to play against especially if you're
kind of newer in chess
exactly you have to note that you you
can only successfully meet Knight to G5
uh with a quick Pawn to D5 or castles in
this case just like you said we have a
totally symmetrical position this is
actually excellent stuff
from uh from saikuno as long as he
castles there's another way to play this
where you play Pawn to H6 with black and
then you play Pawn to G5 and you just
attack white because White Castle then
you didn't that's hey I'm trying to plan
on the other side
um yeah just totally totally good
um of course
oh Bishop G5 we're getting a pin on the
Knight and the Knight is looking towards
D5 this is another very scary threat to
deal with but like who knows gonna deal
with uh the attack by just going on
offense himself to start off
yeah he played A6 to play B5 that that
was that was the reason for that uh the
computer isn't super happy about it
because not because of that move but
because of the bishop coming here with
some pressure uh now this is a very
strong move that was a big inaccuracy
from saikuno he should have taken with
the queen uh now he's gonna have some
difficulties castling Bishop D5 is a
very nice move not because you're gonna
win the Knight
because the Knight could be defended but
your light squares are weak and it's
going to be hard to Castle but Frank
might take that I mean he he takes
everything he doesn't he doesn't mind
trading off his Bishops and actually one
of my favorite comments from chat so far
is that he said I don't know how but I
can feel I can hear Frank
we might not know what he's saying but
he's just so animated here I I would I
would love to hear him I would love to
hear him we could probably unmute him on
this overlay but we could also throw up
a full screen of him at some point I
mean saikuno is just very chill he just
he just sort of he just sort of chills
let's check in on Frank what's what's he
got cooking up over there summer winter
okay boom we go there there maybe I
don't know I don't know see this queen
the queen on D1 is looking a little bit
tasty right here oh do I do something
with that Queen
um boom might go there take the night we
give a check there and we could threaten
the
oh this is a juicy position this is a
juicy oh I'm just trading I'm just
trading you were right he traded no
respect for the bishop or the kid yeah
no respect uh but uh not you know uh I I
okay I I feel as though have you ever
have you ever done this thing where you
can play like Word Bingo or or like you
know the based on a certain amount of
things that you spot in day-to-day life
it'll go in a bingo card Frank plays
Word Bingo with himself like if he can
say the word tasty five times in a chess
match like that's it oh my gosh you know
what Frank would be incredible at have
you seen that NPC Tick Tock Trend
um with like ice cream slay Frank
kill it
can you imagine Frank sitting there
going oh that's tasty oh that's tasty
you know and just like you know I can't
do them for him because I'm not Frank oh
that's yeah that might be his route
right there to a nine figure net worth
um that's so good yes yes oh my God we
can't we can't we can't lose Frank yeah
commentate like that the entire no I'm
just kidding in before I get fired I I
can't even think of catch phrases to
that extent I've got to like write them
down yeah he took the night and there
really was no follow-up
um he played Bishop takes that he's like
a mad scientist you know he'll blow up
the lab nine times but on the tenth
he'll he'll invent uh a mineral or an
element now he's got to play moves like
Pawn to D4 or Knight H4 Knight F5
because with Knights versus Bishops you
have to maneuver you have to like not
play into the Bishops
yeah meanwhile uh saikuno needs to
figure out what to do with his King
because he's pushed open his pawns on
the queen side so it's not going to be
as safe for him to Castle there but then
he's also blown up his Pawn structure on
the king side so I guess he's just gonna
have to hang out in the middle for a bit
yeah I also I love how I just predicted
this move I mean it's just it's just one
you're inside Frank's mind and I don't
know if that's a good thing yeah I also
don't know I I it's sort of one of these
things like
as a beginner you you want to go forward
a lot but you don't always know how so
you just go oh can I go there well if
you if they take me I just take and then
you just play the move like there's no
further thought that's a blunder yep
because now now The Rook is no longer
defending this and queen takes Pawn is
vicious and that's the whole byproduct
of flame Pawn takes so is he is he
excited now because he sees it it looks
like that's what's about to happen I
think he's gonna go for it and then F6
is also going to be under attack
although hopefully saikuno will see that
he could trade the Knight for the bishop
and defend it that way I really do want
to know what he's screaming about he he
might be thinking that the Rook is going
to come Checkmate him and then he might
just be like Oh The Rook is coming and I
don't know how to stop it like I I
really I don't know if he's yelling
about The Rook or queen takes Pawn let's
go let's go see he does see it I see him
drawing an arrow I think we're gonna
pull him up right now let's get there
quickly but I don't
I'm scared of what this Rook will do to
me
and go there maybe oh no I can't really
go there okay
I do want to go there though oh goodness
I'm shaking I'm shaking right now okay
[Music]
you know what we could be cooking boom I
go there he takes with Queen then I go
there with night then we get a
disgusting fork okay that could be slimy
that could be slimy and grimy right
there oh please please we need to make
it work babe we need to make it work
right here okay so icono's got eight
minutes
um oh no that's not a good move you know
what
[Music]
I mean
it's it's on the board slimy and grimy
and Knight takes Rook
is just picking up the exchange but I
have really bad news for Frank
the queen and the bishop are still very
very well aligned there's a move here
Queen to G5 that can trade the Queen off
by force
but
then the black Rook comes here and it's
still not over and then he's really
going to be a scared man in a scared
land or whatever he said
yeah and oh oh he saw it
he saw it but so did the computer and
it's very not it's very displeased
because Rook the G8 and the attack
continues yeah he's gonna take on e4 oh
okay well okay that that's not the best
move but psychuno is still hanging on
here I wish he would have seen Rook G8
just to make the game a little bit more
level but he's he's still making threats
and he actually still has the Rook G8
plan regardless
yes exactly Bishop D4 was wrong not
because white could play defense but
because C3 was not just defending but
also creating a threat uh this is wrong
it's not a bad move it's completely
understandable and the Knight has to
retreat for oh my goodness I was just
about to say he's gonna play that move
King G6 King G6
oh my God he saw it five head all right
let's get in there now the Knight has
nowhere where it can go and not be
captured
um that being said Frank at least will
have the Rook for the two Bishops oh my
gosh so much is going on yes I knew
Frank was going to give a check for for
just because he could now the Knight is
in jail if sakuru takes the Knight he
loses his Bishop all he has to do is go
back and the Knight is going to perish
and black is winning because two Bishops
are better than a rook not a pawn a rook
they just are and that there we go Frank
might continue chasing it's like who
knows just gotta keep running this
Knight is is gone
it's just a goner
well rest in peace night he had a long
journey he could have lived many lives
but he's going to end early and not just
as not only is Frank gonna be down
material but now his King might end up
opening up with the two Bishops looking
towards him
yeah this is this is this is really
really bad uh can we check on what
saikuno's thinking the saikuno realize
how good his position is or is he just
is he just sitting there and pretending
not to know what's going on again say
okay okay just like I thought he would
go for a pawn
no he didn't take the night
yeah I had a really bad feeling about
this but but Frank Knight is still
completely trapped I mean saikuru can
just come back for it Rook here or here
and like it it's still dead for sure you
do have those options but I think if
saikuno moved his King away maybe he's
not thinking of that plan and if he's
not aware of it eventually he will give
the Knight an Escape Route although wow
oh my God
we don't even have to check in he has
found Pawn to G3 uh he he is like
hyperventilating he and his Knight is
gonna get trapped his nice sister now he
came back and fixed his mistake which is
always a good thing to do you don't have
to find it the first time just correct
it at least
yeah unbelievable stuff a move ago the
reason why King takes F5 was wrong was
because white could give an anchor to
the Knight with H4
and Knight and Knight G5 and uh
I'm just gonna start yelling out random
emotes chat let me know which ones you
want me to incorporate in next
where did the bishop go saikuno forgot
about his Bishops I could have trapped
at night but he loves the bishop
ah
Pepe please
he just had to stay patient either the
night was so dead
uh
um brutal
yeah but this is POG Champs I mean the
eval bar is having the hardest hardest
day in the office from all of us
yep yep now Frank is the he he's going
full Mr Burns here no saikunos lost the
bishop but Frank's gonna see this in a
heartbeat
oh it's there
it's there and and and that that is it
unfortunately there is a a reason their
ratings are different and it's because
On Any Given move
the accuracy of one of the players is
gonna be higher yes Magnus Carl but not
that's different
yeah yes I couldn't really faded I mean
he was doing really really well
uh
unfortunately he's sort of he's sort of
fallen off and Frank has gotten better
like Frank has gotten stronger as the
game has gone on yes ikuno is just
losing every Pawn now I mean Rook takes
pawn and
yeah
uh Alexandra did you see Frank's first
game of pogchamps that I commentated
with Andrea
um was that the one where he found a
cheeky checkmate
that was the one where he found the
stalemate
he was up a queen in four pawns so uh
I'm not saying that's going to happen
but I'm also not not saying it's not
gonna not happen I don't know I've seen
the craziest stalemates in POG Champs um
it's very valid I wonder if saikuno is
familiar with stalemate because then he
can even try to go and get his King
somewhere where it doesn't have a lot of
squares to escape from although even
when you know stalemates it's hard to
imagine where his King could go like
let's say maybe his King got to H3 and
Frank's Rook is uh covering the G4
Square
ah these are crazy crazy arrows but it
could happen yeah I'm I'm just drawing
this because white could even lose this
game uh for example if whitechest
decides that he wants to move this rook
and take a pawn this King could sneak in
I mean it would not be the first time
that something like that has happened
I've even I've made a video about this
concept like this is a secret way to win
games you just run your king up the
board and people stop they stop
everything they're doing and they start
checking you and all of it and see like
F6 and sneak the king forward
I don't know if he's gonna play the
other moves but now King G6 yeah he just
has to resist the urge to keep moving
his Rook back and forth oh the king
wants to go the other way I understand
why he's doing that he thinks he's
approaching towards the pass Pawn but
he's not going to stop it regardless so
he's gonna have to go for some desperate
attempts here
uh that's yeah that's that's yeah that's
just
now white can give a check and assist
the promotion so Rook B8 and you make a
queen and and I don't think Frank is
going to create a stalemate here but
never said it happened yeah
um all right so what is his best attempt
at a stalemate here
unfortunately I think saikuno is not
allowing many stalemate possibilities uh
yeah this is excellent and now look at
that I mean that's it's more gonna be
frank playing too quickly and getting
too many queens uh more so than saikuno
being able to do anything here
he knows the latter technique oh there
we go oh and The Rook seals it Rook up
Queen forward and and that look at that
wow
well done ggs let's let's check in on
how Frank uh put put the final touches
on this game then we go there then we go
there then we go there okay that's a
Checkmate baby that's a Checkmate right
there oh that took us a little while to
cook okay but we got there in the end oh
my goodness gracious me I was shaking
that entire game this man is too good
158 oh my goodness
and there you have it the first decisive
result of the day Frank has taken a one
to nothing lead over saikuno he was the
favorite in the matchup for sure he's
probably the second seed in the group of
four uh but it was a good fight and
actually for a moment or two Frank was
completely lost but at this level some
of those moments just come down to a
coin flip and if cycuno hadn't
given up his Bishop he would have been
playing for a win yeah but even more
than that it did feel like sakuna was
quickly he still had a lot of
does have the
capacitance out but I don't know if he's
gonna get this feedback in time so yeah
and not everybody is a is a try-harding
chess student right like he he he he
might not really care about going into
those small intricate moments and going
oh I see like the dynamic of the pieces
and why I shouldn't have taken the night
because I could have saved my Bishop
like he's a gamer you know yeah but he's
kind of a god gamer he he
impressive how clever he is about them
which is why I feel like he can
he's still the underdog but he has a
chance oh I I definitely think he can I
I just feel like learning chess is
slightly more frustrating and yeah on a
non-intuitive than learning I don't know
FPS Among Us like a lot of different
games because
it's all so so situationally specific I
mean he his openings are great like he's
obviously not a 150. yeah
if he grinded in the chess.com pool he
would easily get up to four or five
hundred I think yeah
um okay so now psychuno is copying
Frank's opening
same position so far but they flip
colors
Frank okay so Frank allows a fried liver
is he aware that he's allowing the
opening that he plays against everybody
if he is
going for it is is Franklin playing
prepared
is Frank playing the Traxler counter
attack
oh oh my I'm gonna start yelling like
Frank this is oh my goodness Knight
takes pawn and then the queen comes out
have you ever been so proud
I didn't teach him this but maybe he
learned it from me I mean the the tracks
are yours is one of the internet's chest
teacher Levy no the track star is a
special place in my heart this is a
video I made like like way before I mean
Queen's Gambit era you know 2020 like
those Baron days of Chess oh my goodness
but does Frank play Queen H4 does he
lose the game right now does Frank know
what's going on moment of truth I mean
he played it so quickly he must know
what's going oh my God and he remembered
the theory
oh my goodness the game might end with
Knight takes Rook Queen f4j it's mate in
four it's Maiden for okay he plays the
the the the queen of two it's also good
it's also good now there's a force
Checkmate here
does he remember it you have to go D5 or
else you might lose
laughs
I guess we're gonna see just how deeply
Frank went into his homework here
hey oh
he has to find Pawn to D5 check
what's he thinking about can we go to a
stream is he yelling I think maybe D6 if
he misses it might be what he goes for
it's also good
not according to the computer I go okay
boom we go there that blocks off there
there there that's blocking off there
um yeah I feel as though we do go there
okay we go there right that's blocking
off there that's blocking off there
there there
okay okay oh is that just could this be
me okay then I do I go okay do I go
there next
or do okay if I go boom I go there
um if I do I go there yeah he definitely
doesn't know but he could stumble upon
it um
let's bring it up to an analysis board
though he also might win this game by
Brute Force so if Frank plays okay so
he's losing now so the reason why here
is a mistake it's a very natural move
because you're gonna get the bishop but
you gave up everything okay it's like
you know having a huge investment and
and you get like 10 back and that's it
like he's gonna get the bishop but
that's not what he wants yeah main
crypto flashbacks yeah let's not
okay we'll get the bishop we'll pull out
early I uh I don't want to talk about
crypto Bed Bath and Beyond none of that
stuff we're just not gonna even we're
not even gonna Queen takes Bishop is uh
hitting the king but then Pawn here but
if Frank finds D5 that's the winning
move his Checkmate in four yeah but will
zaikudo move the pawn is the question
and he does
oh
wow if saikuno survived I mean a tie
break would be very fun here
um now Frank is just not gonna have
enough pieces in the attack but saikuno
is gonna have to figure out a way to get
his King into Safe Haven and also hey
he's setting up his pieces for the next
game isn't that your line yes he is
setting up his pieces for the next game
yeah but now G3 and and Frank Frank has
messed this up and Traxler players know
this
they get to a position there's an m in
the evaluation like it was right here
but the only way you win is if you play
the move Pawn to D5 you have to get this
bishop in the game D5 doesn't matter if
king take takes and Frank had another
way he could have done it but at this
point Frank is just desperately giving
checks he's giving a check here giving a
check there giving a check there but now
white is just going to develop hopefully
he doesn't lose all his pawns uh and
hopefully he doesn't move his Rook yeah
exactly it doesn't lose his Rook he's
white is up
a rook and the Knight which is a very
good amount of material to be up if you
are not getting checkmated he was
getting checkmated but not anymore
so psychuno just has to move his Knight
here or his Bishop to C3 if he wants to
defend his Rook
um or he could YOLO bring his Queen to
F3 and try to go for Checkmate on F7 and
then f8 yeah exactly Queen F3 he could
have probably even done it last move
like in this position I would not be
shocked if Queen F3 and Rook F1 were
winning of course you don't want to lose
everything but yeah uh Knight D4 is a
fantastic move but if sykuno just
also has to realize just like you said
he he doesn't need to play defense all
the time like he can play Queen H5 and
he will probably win in five moves
should we go over to saikuno and see if
he's thinking about it oh I do see him
arrowing he did look at Queen H5 but
he's he was worried about Knight takes
C2 yeah so
although that doesn't defend against it
because Knight takes C2 is coming in
with check here but at least at least he
saw the Check Yes uh Rook to B1 attacks
the queen now obviously Queen takes Pawn
would be terrible
because Frank doesn't want to trade
Queens what does saikuno think
someone said I would bet my entire life
savings Frank wins or draws this well I
hope you at least put your channel
points out there thinking hard about
this move
let's see what would I do if I were him
I would probably just move this back
somewhere far not here but like
honestly I just move it all the way back
there or something I don't know
um
I guess you could thank you listen to
saikuno when you're ready to go to sleep
because it's so cool it's Frank as
you're an alarm clock
do about it
um
okay
unless well
this is great but it's too calm for me
it's it's unnerved you're right no it it
definitely is uh Knight takes C2 check
is a very natural move
but
it's horrendous for black because and I
don't blame Frank at all uh after King
F1 by some sort of Miracle Black's only
move is Queen here uh and then you're
just gonna lose the Knight he could find
Knight E3
and then losing the night for that night
instead of just losing the night for
nothing
but but it's over I mean he's losing all
his pieces and and this is the issue
like you you have to understand your
opening but you have to know the the key
idea and the key idea is to add this
bishop and if you don't
uh Frank had another chance I think I'm
just gonna quickly show as we wait for
the next move he could have gone for
this and there was a chance that he I
don't know how but somehow could have
checkmated like this
and hunted the king but all of that did
not happen and he is losing by a lot of
material he did find Knight E3 though
Frank's been cooking
I'm not surprised he found it his
tactics have been pretty good
um but at this point he is down a rook
and a knight
it might just be too much material to
come back from but weirder things have
happened do we consider this a real
disadvantage for black I mean does white
even remember he has a knight well I
mean it could be an advantage for it as
well if he somehow gets his Queen to F7
but you're right it's all on how he
plays this queen B3 would be a
simplifying move for him obviously yeah
Queen H5 is better but
uh uh oh H4 is crazy that that is a like
saikuno having and I try to tell
beginners like you're up so much
material what are you doing pushing upon
you gotta use your your forces here
right you got to get the queen always
look for checks that was the only check
white hat it also happened to be a great
move and Frank found this and he's
winning the night what a ridiculous move
by the way yeah I know I I think a lot
of newer players just start Panic
pushing their pawns when they don't know
how to continue
um so if that's one of you guys in chat
you can you can learn from this game but
at least what he's doing is being forced
to move his King off of the open file
which would then open it up for his Rook
but he might just continue pushing pawns
based on what we've seen
yes ikuno's got to move the king and
then and then actually like end the game
he has to get the queen in The Rook
together he's got to attack the king but
if he just yeah exactly if he just moves
his pawns I
somebody in chat said Panic pushing has
helped me with many games at my 250
level and for sure it's gonna work a lot
in those early stages but Frank is too
strong to just be pushed around from
pawns oh
you saw it there you go
that's a great move now oh and Frank is
smart he's gonna get the bishop out but
psychuno could end everything right now
I mean the computer is such a scumbag
like yeah I mean it's considering all
these moves uh obviously blunders Bishop
E6 Rook takes Pawn is just
screaming to be played this is a check
that's a check saikuno is just not using
his Queen that's what is that where is
he going here
is he doing this what's he doing what is
this move is he doubling he plays Queen
C1 I'll respect it it's a good plan oh
no more Pawn pushes but now he's opening
up The Rook I hope he sees oh this queen
is under attack oh I don't I I don't
want to look I don't want I'm closing my
eyes I'm not looking no way no he's
gonna see it lovey don't worry
although this feels like one of those in
before moments just can't just can't
even just
there you go there you go oh oh thank
God you can open your eyes it's okay now
it's safe loving you can come on oh God
that was terrifying and Frank better not
play Rook takes Rook I mean he's played
enough chess games when you're down this
much material you don't trade if he
trades I'm gonna have to yell at him
just move your Rook over gotta preserve
The Rook
uh oh
do you see what move he's hovering over
Levy Mike put the Rook down you
absolutely just
okay he put the Rook back he he did in
fact we're looking we're looking behind
the scenes here
he had his hand like this I mean The
Rook became a black Rook he had it right
there oh that's
genius and terrible at the same time
because if you take you lose your queen
but now he's forced to trade everything
so it's all on saikunai oh here he's
trying to bait him although I guess I
respect it because when you're down so
much material sometimes you got to go
for things that are incorrect but if
they somehow work out you get to come
back and on move 28 we have the first
check of the game by white which is
Queen to G4 if sakuru had found a check
10 moves ago he would have won uh now he
gives a check
I don't even know what Frank is thinking
about does he even realize this Chuck
what he's he's thinking of this move
okay
[Music]
he's just hovering he's just hovering
and and now that saikuno got his Queen
off of the D file his Rook is free to
take the bishop on A2 after so that was
a very nice tactic that he found yes I
have no evidence at all if that was his
idea
oh you think he might have just been a
check and he's like yeah yeah let's do
it yeah I don't know I mean Rook takes
Bishop was not possible as you said uh
but now it is
I can't believe Frank is still thinking
I mean goodness gracious what is he
thinking about
okay I see a lot of people cheering for
saikuno in the chat now
um okay chat spam who we are supporting
for here
yeah I like that there's Die Hard fans
on both sides all right let's check in
on Frank I don't know I don't know
what's going on over there but I think
he's convinced he can't move his King
chaos yeah
uh okey-dokey
um
uh what play do I make here okay we'll
just go there oh he's won a bishop that
was foul that was absolutely foul right
there holy guacamole that was well takes
it quickly
even if you didn't see it right away if
you start when it counted that was not
yeah that was that that was very very
well done I have no idea if that was
even like the intention but I think
Frank's
time spent on that move definitely
allowed saikuno to uh to to build up
kind of like that energy you know the
the confidence and be like okay Rook A5
now okay the last thing that's remaining
in this game is saikuno has to launch a
massive attack toward this King when
you're up this much material you could
make it an end game uh or you can launch
a huge attack Queen A6 now is a violent
move because you can't take the Rook due
to very much it's very hard to see here
yeah that's gonna happen and I do see
that psychuno does like moving Rooks we
saw that earlier when we were a little
bit confused why he was pushing his Rook
up to the second rank I think he
understands the concepts of doubling
Brooks and he's maybe just mistaking
when to do it in the game
yeah totally like Rook A5 he also could
have just thought that this was hanging
now he's like I can't take it
um the only way he loses this game is
with the queen sniping a rook from the
corner of the board so right like Frank
might go Queen f8 here threatening the
rook and hang the queen to the other
Rook votes gamut op oh that would be
you know with Frank I just must I I
don't think he he lives with like
roommates or or his parents or anything
but if he does Imagine just listening to
him outside of the room and then finding
out what he's actually doing
I think I think he lives with his family
yeah I don't they must have really thick
walls over there like
or they sound proof the room or he
streams in the basement you know I
rookie oh
setting it up
he's setting up rook takes Queen takes
Queen takes Rook that's that's what he
wants it doesn't work at all make no
mistake it is absolutely not a good move
but nothing was a good move okay
the computer is so evil look it says
every move Frank plays as bad
just every move that he's playing is a
double question mark but what do you
want him to do you scumbag yeah and I
mean the computer accuracy is not that
good when you're already lost because
again sometimes it's better to make
moves that are not good they'll give you
a better chance
um I would love for saikuno to see the
idea of getting his Queen to A6 and and
just seeing him complete his attack here
yeah I
saikuno should be able to just trade and
I mean he could go for the king he could
just defend himself
you got to make sure everything is
defended you got to trade the Queens if
you can uh I think I saw Danny in the
chat of course uh Danny wrench Danny
wrench and he said I don't think I've
seen Frank stop talking for more than
two seconds ever and that is not even an
exaggeration like I
during our lesson we did a lesson
together
I think he was exploding because he
couldn't speak he he is like the those
commercials back in the day for the
candy the Airhead candy yeah he's like a
exploding balloon of energy
it's unnerving I think saikuno might go
here and hang his Rook by the way like
it's just one of these moves I go here I
face your pawn and then boom but he
should double that's really what he
should do and I feel like he was
preparing to double so
I think
okay I mean he doubled in one way he
should be doubling on the D file
um and not on the fourth rank but he is
putting pressure towards E4 so that's
that's good yeah it's very nice that
he's doing it this way also he has a
very nice configuration here Queen
Bishop you got the Rooks he's staring
down right here uh so I like what he's
doing he could just eat just that's all
he's got to do just eat
uh and then he's got to go for checkmate
that's that's all that's all that's
preventing him from sending this to a
playoff How likely do you think
because I think chat might think that
it's finished but definitely not no it's
like a it's like 70 I mean it is not it
is so losable
with the queen on the diagonals I mean
it's it's still like it's a solid 70 but
Queen D5 and you lose the Rook like you
know what I mean yeah
and queen H1 is a fork but you can't go
there but that would be nice
I will say from what I've seen so far
psychuno has had trouble finishing off
the attack
um and he maybe hasn't learned yet the
idea of trying to trade when you're up
pieces so those are the two main things
that would help him win this game
oh rookie rookie eight this is why you
always have to look for checks and it's
on the board what okay there you go tie
break hey Levy you're gonna actually
have to explain that that's fun yeah no
the tiebreak is this is our third match
in a row that's gonna go to I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say anything this I
couldn't know how to checkmate
I mean he has another Pawn he can always
get another queen he's gonna get two
greens yeah uh count the the chicken
before it's hatched oh that that that's
mate right there Queen Aid is made in
one by the way
both are good here oh is he gonna take
the pawns is he gonna take there's a way
you could still oh oh oh oh
Moment of Truth yeah good job sorry Kuno
wow all right let's go check it on
psychuno's last moves 200 rated now
wow 32 rating for one game not bad not
bad
nice
oh my God
what a rating change for saikuno he's
still okay is he still provisional or
are you gaining more when you're that
terrible I think it's a mix of both I
think chess.com is trying to throw you
out of the 100 area so fast to make you
feel good but I mean it's one to one
this is unbelievable Frank is an 800
consistent rapid player and saikuno just
defeated him granted
granted the opening was a bit crazy
because Frank went all in with an
aggressive attack and he had a mate like
the attack worked but he didn't play the
mate so he just spent the whole game
down the material so I couldn't have
played well made almost no mistakes and
converted and uh now we have uh yeah we
have a uh a playoff for the third time
in a row so I'm just gonna explain to
the audience real quick and then we will
make our predictions and and so on uh
the players now will play a three-minute
Blitz game with five seconds bonus time
so they play 10-5 normally they're now
playing three minutes to five seconds
bonus uh White is going to be determined
by the higher accuracy of the previous
two games right so uh I I think it's
highest overall but it might be the
average regardless the person that was
more accurate over the last two games is
going to play with white and I'm going
to be told momentarily
I have been told as I said that it's
Frank Frank had the higher accuracy over
the past two games and therefore he is
going to start with white a lot of these
players have one with white in the rapid
matchup and then they have uh they have
uh prevailed in the tie break but
that's not always guaranteed oh and if
you're wondering what happens if it's a
draw they just change colors we had that
yesterday we had double overtime with
Gastly and sapnap that match was insane
wow yeah no Armageddon here and uh going
into the tie breaks we know that Frank
is the favorite
um but it's kind of interesting because
in this game he lost
almost because he knew too much Theory
but not enough to get all the way
exactly
uh he almost won unfortunately like
Frank almost once I couldn't almost lost
but sometimes that's just life
uh but you know what one thing that we
are really not talking about that I will
talk about right now Frank is a 200 ELO
Blitz player
like he doesn't play Blitz he plays
rapid he mostly plays rapid I would have
talked so quickly he's clearly able to
think quickly although he has been lower
on time for both games yes he has been
lower on time and there you go 253 he is
only 15 points higher rated than saikudo
he goes for he goes for Vienna this time
but
or I don't know I don't know if he's
gonna play the game oh wow he does play
the Gambit for the second time in the
tie break sapnap did this yesterday
against Gastly uh oh basically think
he's this rating in Blitz because he
can't stop talking and it's distracting
from his time look at saikuno he's he's
talking a lot less now yeah and saikuno
is just sort of like I don't know and
and Frank Frank you moved upon there
because you can see he's got to take now
saikuno can't go forward this is very
tough he's he's lost no yep yep
will Frank see it though oh yeah he has
an attack on the queen but Queen takes
Pawn is vicious
castling there's Bishop uh there's we
gotta move the pawn and then get the
bishop out to this H6 Square
yeah
but Alexandra it's not over he might
still lose the queen oh God oh God
I would no because even if he doesn't
see the the threat on his Queen I think
he's gonna see the G7 Pawn and he did he
took it he took it so
now saikuno oh no it's Rook Ah that's so
sad oh Knight D5 is violent oh Queen E5
is eating everything I'm telling you all
y'all gotta start playing this Vienna
Gambit sapnap did it yesterday against
Gastly got a winning position
yeah yeah people are just not used to it
and it's not what they find when they're
studying the basics and then if you try
to apply the same rules that you're used
to it doesn't work which is why it's so
good at beginner levels
listen I'm I'm beating jams with it too
I'm just saying but uh but at beginner
level he loves it I I will they'll put
the Vienna on my Tombstone oh Knight
season oh this is a feast this is a
feast let's check in on Frank's stream
real quick if we can I think I think
Frank is eating he's eating like early
Thanksgiving dinner
and what season would it be in
Thanksgiving like what is happening we
can go back
oh my goodness I'm just destroying
what okay okay okay okay okay okay we'll
go there next okie dokie what okay we're
just up by 18 right now we are up by 18.
what what is going on what is going on
right here okay we'll Castle up okay as
long as we just get pieces involved
right here we should be looking very
tasty okay okay
um all right all right I love that the
way you think you're sort of by clicking
random pieces
is a stale made of some sorts uh it's
mate Knight C7 is mate the Knight comes
back from the dead oh my gosh
he touched the Knight oh no Bishop there
oh but psychunos just hell-bent on
losing every piece I mean it's just
uh but again if he loses every piece he
might be able to stalemate
yeah you're right though now he plays
Knight C7 Frank's accuracy is 95 right
now
wow
is this Frank's best game ever or
saikuno's worst game ever
both mix of both but that this is why I
told Frank to play the Vienna and he's
like I don't know it well he knew it
pretty damn well in this game night back
to A8 by the way very
very B4 Pawn mate Rook mate
oh it's on the board
and Frank with Rook C4 Checkmate let's
go check in are we gonna check it on the
last move of the game there well nicely
done Frank he finishes off very nice
yeah give a check all right we're gonna
go oh and that's okay what's on Earth
I just don't what what
he didn't even know it was made twice
um what happened he played so well what
happened I'm guessing Blitz is just
another Frontier what I don't know what
just happened right there
okay I mean I'll take it but what on
Earth what on Earth
well what on Earth is that Frank just
beat saikuno in resounding fashion that
had a lot less to do with saikuno and a
lot more to do with the Vienna the
opening that Frank played so Frank
victorious in our first matchup of the
day in the tie break so he will earn two
points for his group standings uh and
saikuno will earn one saikuno came to
play I mean he defeated somebody rated
800. what are your impressions of what
you just saw
that last game was wild I agree with
your analysis I think
saikuno was definitely the underdog
going into this and that ended up
happening but what I do but what I will
say is that if saikuno has little tips
going into the next game I think he
could be able to make a pretty big jump
and even if he doesn't make it into the
championship bracelet he has a good
chance for the Challenger the bracelet
was that like a poker Freudian slip yeah
it was you know what I meant
honestly we should like it's a live
final you know what Ludwig you're you're
helping organize the whole thing make a
beautiful golden bracelet for the winner
of the live final and we'll put it on
them it's gonna have chess I'll have
Mogul moves on it's a genius idea look
at that that would be so cool that's
what yeah at Ludwig if you don't do it
you're a scumbag now you heard it you
got to watch party going on they'll
probably all hear the pressure's on you
here are the group standings of group a
Sea Dog up top with Five Points
yesterday winning in a tie break fashion
over Jarvis Frank pulling it off versus
saikuno this was always expected but the
most fun matchup is yet to come in this
group because it's going to determine
who is the winner of group a and that
matchup still hasn't happened yet it's
not happening later it's happening at
another date Sea Dog versus Frank uh
Alexander who do you think is the
favorite in that matchup given
everything you've seen
well well see dog is still higher
higher so objectively I'll say he is the
favorite but I mean we can tell from
these games that Frank has been studying
and sometimes that studying has helped
him cook
oh it's absolutely helped him cook that
was an incredible game this is
everything I wanted from group a I
wanted Frank to start strong uh and I
got good news everybody we are going to
be right back that's not the good news
but the good news is we are bringing
back the one and only Frank the Tank
Woodley for an interview don't go
anywhere
thank you
[Music]
so potentially be still made but no
Ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment I didn't realize
there was increment yes there's a two
second increment so three minutes plus
two second increment he has now
collected a lot of time went all the way
up
oh
[Music]
yes yes
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
Benji the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chess board
watch out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
honchick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
I was here I was lost oh okay well hey
let's go oh no I think you should have
just done that sure I got 14. we beat it
let's go no 15 unreal no first try eight
in a row nine in a row baby let's go
let's go let's go I gotta oh cool I got
a little achievement thing I honestly
really enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back everyone there we see Frank
and a couple of highlights from his
matchup that just concluded
versus saikuno Alexandra is allergic to
the chess on the screen yeah Frank
taking a sip of the water and this was
the big moment Rook to C4 the Checkmate
that we didn't even know was Checkmate
because of the odd configuration of the
knights on the back rank the good news
is we are now joined
all the way from the UK Frank Frank how
are you
I'm I'm feeling great I did not expect
that last game that was insane even for
me so I'm feeling good I'm feeling great
how was the match relative to to how you
thought it was gonna go what do you know
about saikuno other that other than that
he's a hundred
well I saw his match against Sea Dog and
he did look he did look better than his
level was
um but I I still thought I'd win right
I'm not not trying to like I I because I
just thought he is
yeah I still thought I'd win but he is
very good I didn't expect him to be this
good I was amazed
by that well it looks like you've been
taking your chests very seriously and
that you've clearly been preparing your
theory as we saw when you're reacting
and blitzing out against the fried liver
attack
how much chess have you been studying
going into this
um I mean uh done a few here and there
you know a few little bit of studying
not as much as I should have but um
still did a little bit uh I'm gonna be
on some quite a lazy person but I I try
and work when I need to
Frank the second game is the Traxler the
something that's you've been playing a
lot of is that what you normally play
well I played it once uh I played it
once right and then every single other
time I've forgotten how to play it so I
kind of play something in the variation
of it but after around the fifth move of
it I just don't know what to do and I
just Panic so that's what happened there
yeah you had a you actually played it
perfectly you just had to move your deep
on so if you're gonna if you're gonna do
any more chests today spend 30 seconds
and just re-watch either the stream or
just analyze the game you you almost
played it so perfectly it looked great
but then you pulled off the the Vienna
you just took everything you were a
vacuum cleaner in the last game
I wait I'm supposed to be for D Pawn I
didn't know that I just thought the
Napoleon was like a statue in the middle
in your game it definitely was but you
know you had to move it it was great
though I mean uh I I asked um your
future opponent your your last opponent
of group a I asked him this question
yesterday uh do you feel do you feel any
emotions going into that Master versus
Sea Dog because you have a chance to win
group a and you have a chance to be the
number one rated player in the event and
there's the whole England and and and
Wales rivalry right how how strong are
all the emotions going into that matchup
I mean I obviously want to beat the best
guy in the group I want to show him
who's boss and
um brother well should you have a nice
flag but um yeah obviously I'm guessing
there is some rivalry there gonna win it
for the English people
um gonna win the Rivalry because
we're hoping to anyway
well yeah before we go I know we have to
soon but Frank Levy was really loving
your rant on the seasons and the weather
but he was getting a little bit lost do
you mind explaining it to him just uh
slightly
um well pretty much I was saying that
the seasons there's like it it matches
on like the weather and it matters on
the festivals in the season because they
make the season the season they make it
what it is because some is hot and it's
nice but winter it's cold and bad but
you got the whole Christmas thing and
that's just bringing it all together
that's all the festivity you see that's
why like the festivals make it what it
is
sorry I I was crying because I actually
cried when you went in on this rant uh
the first time I I was just overwhelmed
with emotion uh because I learned so
much uh Frank
um
we we got to get on to our second
matchup of the day but we both wanted to
congratulate you on a huge win uh
congrats on winning literally almost all
of the pieces of your opponent in the
tie break uh and uh we wish you all the
best in your in your last matchup in
group a we'll talk to you soon thank you
very much thank you very much goodbye
bye Frank that was a that was a touching
moment and now we are going to take a
look at our next matches for the day
nothing will be as profound as this one
but we've got daily dose of Internet
versus sapnap followed by I did a thing
versus Papa Plata uh I do believe uh
daily doses we just we just rolling
straight into that we're about a minute
or two away uh from a start there
okay so who is your favorite and not
your favorite who do you think is the
favorite going into this
I don't know uh uh I am not going to say
anything until they start playing
because I have I am biased
and I I have worked with sapnap a bit
not because I don't like daily dose we
see them there but I don't know him as
well and that's just how it goes right
you don't know some people so you know
you the the betheses know him Andreas
helped him out a little bit he he's he
was very good in his matchup versus
Gastly but he came up short
um and he did not get on the scoreboard
in the group he is looking like a killer
I mean he looks like a UFC fighter or a
serial killer who knows you know like
sitting in the darkness oh my God yeah
but by the way
um Andrea mentioned he's traveling in
Europe and isn't virtual also aren't
they in the same place are they I heard
he was in Norway which is you know
pretty good Chester yeah and that's
where virtual is because I saw in a
Kremlin tweeted she's why don't they
just meet up and fight like why the CH
just just play the Chess Live maybe they
can do both
uh yeah I know actually that would be
cool having all the POG Champs Games
Live would be sick can't do it because
of production but
it would be way more intense although I
don't know how you'd be able to handle
all the all the Talking during
no I I yeah I I don't know uh but there
we have we see sapnap sapnap did mention
to me yesterday he was super motivated
he was really bummed about his like the
the the worst part about the matchup
yesterday versus Gastly is like you play
Four intense games it's like an hour and
a half and you lost like you lost you
lost the match right but he can still
fight his way and uh rematch him in the
I'm calling it the championship bracelet
we're gonna we're gonna Manifest this
right because if you both make it to a
bracket uh you just play other people
and then you you might meet up in the
end anyway but exactly this is the group
of death like sapnap was very very very
motivated to win this tournament and do
well uh
but there are no guarantees and I mean
his group is all over the place he was
higher rated by 200 points yesterday but
I think ghastly might be the best chess
player in the whole group like I haven't
seen virtual play yet but he was
ridiculous yeah I mean well Gastly has
has been a fan of chess for a really
long time
um so maybe he only started playing
online recently so it doesn't reflect
his writing
oh well that would make sense yeah I
mean if he's been grinding uh versus
Bots or he's just sort of like a big
study guy like again we see Frank
mentioned it himself he's a bit lazy I'm
also a bit lazy I don't take my chest
training seriously at all and if you
actually really study the game of chess
it'll it'll pay off well I guess that's
why you and uh Frank might have
something in common with your goals and
if they get hit or not you know
you know uh oh we have F4 oh sapna
busting out a Gambit look at this E5
I may or may not have had something to
do with this
um this is why are you teaching
everybody the gambits well I told him
that listen daily dose likes to play a
bird and in the bird there's a lot of
these lines where you can get a big
attack you can take but the bishop and
the king is going to be open but daily
dose is solid he's not taking everything
he's just
you know responding there we go now
hopefully sapnap doesn't rush because
Knight takes obviously there's Queen
here but there is Pawn to G3 so you
don't but oh Bishop D look at that
beautiful
he is developing his pieces even though
he gave up upon a pawn doesn't mean as
as much as it does at our level so I
think sacrificing getting the
development is easily worth it
absolutely now black black is still
totally fine here because White's King
is a little bit weak so you can play
moves like Bishop here to try to remove
the Knight so you could put your queen
on the H4 Square uh there's also crazy
stuff like G5 G4 you could actually do
anything oh
sapped up is just going for the kill oh
my goodness I mean you did say it's made
it's
it's no it's mayhe oh my goodness zapdam
is a genius
does he see it
no he's hovering over the g-pawn he's
hovering over the g-pawn oh snap them
it's all gone so well it's perfect the
opening went so well Bishop G3 is mate
can we tune in
oh my goodness
that does not seem like it's gonna be so
easy it's on the it's just right there
he's always said he's bad at puzzles
when they're live in games it's the only
check
wait
it's Checkmate oh
my God yes
all right
I think daily dose has also seen it
check me
oh my holy
I need to see that it's a clip
wow
oh my goodness he slowed down he was
just about to go G5
takes a one to nothing lead in five
minutes of play time
yeah daily dope and this is your daily
dose of blunders he is looking into the
camera
he laughed he seems to be taking it well
wow I guess the craziest move won
that was incredible and sapnap did that
completely on his own because daily dose
responded perfectly to that aggressive
stuff and I I was just sitting here like
well we're just gonna have a long game
but he reacted to the pawn threat and
Bishop g3's just game over that was that
was that was the fastest game of the
event but
that's the danger right of playing F4
and the Dutch with black it's just you
you've got to keep your king safe well
this might have actually been the
shortest game in pogchamp history was
this six moves well it was the same it's
time for it's tied yeah it's tied it's
black sixth move yeah and I've been
there for both maybe I'm the problem
no I I think listen I think it's a
byproduct of of of f4
um and that's you know
it do be like that sometimes wow that is
a that is a massive result G5 was
brilliant that was a brilliant move by
sapnap I mean Mike but I don't think he
would I don't think he knew because he
was just trying to push his G Pawn all
the way I mean if he had pushed it and
knew he was inducing mate absolutely and
I still gotta give him credit for
finding it and pausing but he was trying
to play Queen H4 that's what he was
trying to he was trying to bring his
Queen out but daily dose played
perfectly and he was just gonna
consolidate and I I noticed that with
his chest like he is so solid he's so
good but
oh my goodness yeah that that does
happen and wow that is uh you couldn't
have asked for a better start I mean no
well you know for daily dose's sake it
is painful to lose in six moves
hopefully he has a better second game
and has a comeback and I can at least
fight it in tie breaks
yeah I mean well daily dose with black
is is also a very very good player and
he can obviously get the job done we saw
this yesterday in sapnaps match somebody
won right sapnap begins with E4 daily
dose yeah he just plays E5 right we see
sapnap also going for a Vienna we have
lots of viennas
uh I I take no no I I am not responsible
for anything that happens I've never
seen so many viennas in a Pog Champs and
I've never seen you teach so many people
I'm not saying something is happening
here but listen I I only teach two
people you know there's 16 participants
everybody's coaching all right sapnap is
playing the Vienna Gambit it completely
in the Heat this is not this is not the
Vienna game bitty this is the sapnap
Gambit right here but he's he's still
going for it
okay can can we talk a little bit about
F6
um that's not a movie you usually want
to play as black on move two I wonder if
maybe he confused it because if he had
his Pawn on D5 then E6 and C6 would work
so you just gotta shift all the pawns
over one rank yep that's also a better
like the light scores are better to set
up with because the king is safer uh we
I didn't really have any input for sap
dance wide openings like specifically
for this matchup I just showed him the
Vienna and I said you can play it if you
want uh but this uh yeah this I did
notice when I looked at dailydoses games
and
it's not great but for this level it's
fine like as long as he
at least gets the other pieces out I
don't like how he's negating the
development of his other pieces though
yeah I agree and uh this Pawn structure
is gonna make it even more difficult
because now he can't put his Knight on
F6 yep um but you know what it's only
upwards after that last game
yes there is no way to win in two moves
here for white in fact white is playing
his sixth move we've already crossed the
threshold of the last game yeah uh but
yet like see this is the issue oh man
daily dose is really winging it he's
really really winging it do you think
he's tilted because he's just pushing
his pawns before he's moved any of his
pieces they're all still on the back
rank
yeah maybe honestly like
um
I I'm not sure this is a very different
daily dose than the one uh I saw in uh
in his matchup versus Gastly I mean they
had he he was ridiculous
in that match what time is it in Norway
can we say maybe it's just too late I'm
just trying to find uh you know some
some tangible excuses here man maybe you
know maybe maybe it's the lights maybe
it's maybe maybe
uh F5 is a fantastic move by sapnap I
mean it's 11 p.m some people go to bed
early Chad all right doesn't Magnus like
wake up at this hour to go to Raves and
stuff
Magnus Raves now I I see more as a bar
guy
he played a a whole tournament on a DJ
set oh I did see that I did see that
um even though
you know the chess and DJing it doesn't
mix unless you bring chessboards
otherwise it's a little confusing but
okay so so back to the game
um sapnap has taken a lot of space
C5 yeah yeah I don't actually think
that's
terrible because at least you can
control the D4 square and bring his
Knight to C6 and D4 yeah it's certainly
not terrible the night going there is
not nothing uh but the bishop on C4 will
be just just an absolute God uh Pawn to
C3 is a fantastic move but obviously
just don't go Bishop B5 it's a very
natural move for a beginner
and I I like as you get stronger it's
just you realize it's a Swiss cheese
position so the light squared Bishop is
just and of course there's also stuff
like this
so
yet what daily dose did wrong in this
game is he committed three pawns to dark
squares and gave up the light squared
Bishop the good news is
right like it's like this you
start you're usually just thinking
Bishop is worth three Knight is worth
three the trade is fine but then as you
evolve you just notice where is your
opponent putting their pawns what color
um I do know though that sapnap has been
really enjoying attacking daily dose so
I imagine he's gonna go for some Pawn
pushes himself and then he goes A3 so oh
oh my goodness all right here comes 194
uses this this is the comeback of daily
dose right now I mean he's gotta find
one of these two moves he cannot go if
he plays Queen E3 I will
vomit he's gotta defend the C pawn and I
think he sees that
um he might also play Queen D1 just go
back retreating here it's obviously not
as good as keeping his Queen active but
he has three good options so he should
be fine
he's uh let's check in on him he's
highlighting stuff right now
we go here and just protect the square
yeah we go here and protect the square
we need to get this pesky
dude
um out of here I don't like this Knight
I was like yeah I need to stop from
going there I also need to stop it from
just being an annoying little punk
it's definitely a less chatting matchup
than before
yeah
okay
yep
let's let's bring it back to the
analysis board yeah both these guys are
are laser focused
uh sapnap's thought process is really
really good also he's very experienced
didn't he like win or get runner up in a
in a bow test tournament he did we had a
tournament for Minecrafters and he ended
up winning it even though he was not the
favorite in the tournament so he's very
capable of playing great and he trains
his tactics he loves chess
Knight E7 I'm liking that daily dose is
starting to develop his pieces and he'd
rather trade off his Knight on E7 for
the center night on D5
this is a great move from from daily
dose and uh he he's very quickly making
a comeback in this game it's a very
close position because uh both sides
have eight pawns which is the way you
determine that and close positions are
tough this could potentially be a game
changing move though Bishop C4 is
fantastic if he lands a bishop on D5 and
it lives there the rest of the game I
mean it's like a lighthouse it just
I mean this is a beautiful position to
just explain why you want your Bishop on
the opposite color of Pawns
yep
maybe B5 I've seen daily dose play a
move like B5 or maybe it was virtual uh
not not virtual it was ghastly they had
a game and there was a night in the
center and the pawn went here but I
think it was ghastly who moved his pawns
like that uh if I remember okay A5 it's
not quite the same man daily dose loves
dark squared pawns I mean six out of
eight
and uh hopefully he's oh I guess he
can't even really Castle here because
the bishop on C4 is looking towards his
King and now that he pushes Pawn on the
queen side he's probably just gonna have
to keep his King in the center uh which
does seem to be a theme that we're
seeing in POG Champs today
there there is castles now B5 is winning
the problem with this move is that 92 is
a fork okay that was just played way too
quickly yeah that that's not
that was just tunnel vision that was
like I pushed my pawn and I pushed my
Pawn again he had to just take a moment
and go I have a fork the bishop sees
that so let me do something about the
bishop that's when you take and your
opponent was huh stupid and then you get
this and who's stupid after all right
yeah that's I mean it's easy to Tunnel
when you have a plan that you're just
go for and when your opponent makes the
move that looks obvious like like
castling you just sometimes miss it but
wow sapnap sees it he defends it holy
smoke sap now he's playing some great
chess yeah King H1 is wow is what the
grand Masters call a prophylactic move
he saw that and he went here that's nuts
and now now there's there's no more
problems I mean a knight is not getting
to G3 anytime soon and this is not open
I mean if sapna plays G4 on the next
move he should never play chess again
but uh like I mean if you put your king
here that's not actually a bad move
Queen A5 looking for a queen trade I
don't hate it but Saddam might avoid it
he might do that that's totally fine
yeah I I like it because daily doses
King is a little bit in a more dire
situation than white since he's not
going to be able to Castle
um that being said though daily dose
needs to be fighting for a win
but again
trading the Queens is good for him so
yeah there's there's also nothing wrong
with Queen takes Queen but uh there is
in the sense that
black snipe becomes very powerful has
you you recreate this weakness the best
move for white in this position is
probably to slide out of the way and
then kick this Knight out and Black's
position hinges upon this B5 move yeah
which is I think yeah I was just gonna
say it's a bit too sophisticated I do
like the idea of Queen G3 I know it
gives up the pawn on C2 but then you
could take the Knight on E7 and really
start getting up in Black's King
yep Queen G3 looks good
uh I think we have the the Dual sided
view of both the players I don't know if
we're gonna put that up but they uh it's
just good to see them representing and
by the way he does play Queen D3 that
that is crazy like that is a very good
move it's the best move but it's not
according to the computer because of B5
yeah so like it's the best move
versus stockfish
yep I mean if daily those plays B5 I
will lose it that's but that but he's
been pushing his pawns I I would
actually expect him to see this because
he's focusing on the queen side he's
been pushing the pawns as far as he can
yeah that's kind of what I expected I
expected him to try to relieve the
pressure now Bishop takes Pawn takes
would be would be would be nuts like he
would have to see a ghost to not take
with the bishop
Pawn takes is like moving into an
apartment with no windows I don't know
why you would ever do that to the sport
bishop and yeah yeah this is look at it
it's doing the wooden Shield strongest
technique out there shout out to
pogchamps one yeah that was good times
man I remember when the wooden Shield
was brand new Bing Bang Pow bing boom Oh
those were simpler days they were they
were
um
yeah Queen G3 still a possible idea here
seven half just slowly moving out of his
frame
while daily dose looks like he's a photo
he's so focused I don't even know if
he's still breathing
I know we gotta we gotta have heart rate
monitors on him we do have to do it for
one of these POG Champs maybe for the
final that would be sick
that would be sick yeah if we get heart
rate monitors Ludwig first you got to do
the bracelet now you got to do the heart
rate monitor apparently he's not
watching so someone's gonna have to clip
this and just get it to him um this is
again not a bad move but it's a bad move
because the computer wants to start an
attack so like for humans I think this
is fine
this is also a nice move now we'll set
that take
so if he takes he gets rid of his Bishop
which is controlling so much of the
board here
um but if he leaves the Knight there the
Knight is kind of annoying and it's
extremely hard for him to get his Bishop
out of C1 I guess it's not hard he just
moves the queen to C2 and then moves his
Pawn but it feels slow
yeah and it's definitely the best move
because the quality of this bishop
cannot okay give us a check but he's
gonna have to address the Knight on the
next move
and giving up this bishop is completely
fine because this idiot is totally
walled in so you are completely fine
losing the bishop on C1 but this bishop
and especially when you're trying to
attack opposite colored Bishops benefit
the attacking side look at this position
okay rookie two as well
it's it it it's ugly but it's the same
idea okay he's just moving The Rook out
of the way and the only problem though
is because it's gonna lose some tempos I
mean yeah it's gonna be way harder for
him to get his Rook out of A2 and he
won't be able to do it unless he does
trade off that light squared Bishop now
also yeah yeah you're 100 right also I
was highlighting to move the bishop but
the bishop was defended yeah he could
play Queen here first but you're right
uh it would have been better to put the
Rook yeah Queen C4 is fine but now we're
getting tangled very Tangled position
maybe he's gonna play here and move the
bishop but where there and then what
like maybe here Bishop Ah that's oh
that's the best move wow great move he
got it he finally pushed B5 a little
later than anticipated but uh I mean in
some ways uh I was about to say Levy but
sapnab is playing without his work on A2
except
both of them are behind on development
with the Rooks and the bishop
yeah it's exactly right they're both
it's a very weird position this bishop
is locked in this Rook is locked in this
bishop is locked in uh the best move for
black is Queen A8 forcing a queen trade
and white loses a lot of steam
I mean this position is very level it
could go either way okay he doesn't want
to trade yet well King A7 is actually a
good move even though the pawns are on
the fifth rank or further there's no way
that white can attack his King and he is
kind of given space for his Rook on B8
should he ever want to open it up
although he shouldn't soon because then
that Rook on A2 could actually wake up
by the way this is a huge moment I had
highlighted this move and I knew sapnap
was going to go for this because
sometimes he likes things a bit easy
right this is an easy move this is it
but it's not bad Rook B8 is a is a good
move
again the computer doesn't think so
because taking is the best option for
some reason I can't really explain
um but now Bishop D5 has to be played
right now for white to seal off more
squares if he doesn't play that Black's
going here and here and he's gonna be
okay
I mean I actually do like Bishop takes
B3 I know it goes against everything he
said and the positional understanding
here but he needs to get his Rook out
from A2 at some point and he can't just
attack the king with a queen and a
bishop
he can if King A8 is played right like
yeah
that's true yeah like this is not a bad
move
yeah it's only a bad move because of
that and now the Queen's gotta you know
go over here and don't hang the queen in
one move he might just go back
and this is a one of those spots where
daily dose could panic and hang mate oh
my gosh did you see sapnap panicking do
you think he thought he might have lost
his queen or something
I don't know what is he panicking I
don't know he just put his head on his
hands on his head and there was the look
look there for a second
yeah maybe we can see
let's let's look in on his stream
if we can uh he he is looking very
stressed
nope
we go here bring this here
I mean he's on full defense but I mean
we have to bring it here oh
here
oh I I'm not a fan of that move nope
Rook C7 and then there's no oh what does
he do yeah he moved it so he's losing
but it's it's really it's it's
impossible to figure out why
Uh Oh I thought Rook C7 just straight up
worked but then there's Queen E8 and
then and then you actually can't play
bishopy I mean you could play G5 and
Bishop G7 but it is a bit tough to see
wait
so this is nuts he lost the Rook
but the Rook here is completely trapped
so if you take this white is not
actually winning which is unbelievable
because of how powerful this Knight is
and that's why Rook A2 was a mistake to
start off with and usually he would have
better placed his Rook on B1 because
then he could have escaped on the first
rank
let's see if sapping up I mean it's
still pretty good though for sapnap to
take it
is it though
oh not to take the queen you should have
at least gotten the uh Advantage there
he would have taken the Rook he would
have won an exchange which is getting a
rook for a bishop so this is like two
points up
the sapnap Aging 30 years in this match
I mean oh chess is stressful whoa whoa
whoa oh I just saw him play Rook F3 I
was reading chat and I didn't see and
then daily dose didn't take it oh my God
now he's gonna have to go back and waste
moves whoa whoa what what's happening
The Rook is on H6 oh he lost it he lost
division
oh my goodness it's match on daily dose
is about to win with black that was such
a weird sequence of moves
oh my goodness
definitely just doesn't grab the extra
Pawn on D3 but he's gotten his material
back
down
oh my goodness
all right daily dose this is his game
and also he's up two minutes 4 36 for
daily dose versus two minutes and 20
seconds for sapnap uh the increment is
how many seconds is it two no no no it's
five seconds but uh listen sapnap
yesterday uh
uh fought on from a totally totally
hopeless position so he could still find
a way if he eats upon and eats another
pawn and just holds the fort right he
just holds the fort daily dose has been
playing really quickly at some moments
so
he might not be fully accurate also are
we really counting this dark scored
Bishop as a bishop hey
have you not yet but he has hopes oh no
I'm free
Fria
what is he's gonna drink water he just
he just rushed it the sapnaps see Rook
takes Knight oh my goodness
oh my goodness
and he's founded
oh my gosh
or daily dose I mean again the position
is still fine here but he was finally up
chess is really hard for beginners says
Mr cool chess is really hard for
everyone no Rook takes H5
and now sapped up is back to winning
oh he doesn't take it it doesn't take it
this is this is as long as he doesn't
lose remember because he won game one in
it was yeah it's six moves
all right daily dose protecting his Pawn
on H5
um although the trade isn't necessarily
favorable for him here
yeah this the end games are the uh are
the toughest spots so taking is fine put
the bishop here and then infiltrate on
the f file but like
I don't know with a minute 20 it's it
ain't that easy no that's true I mean I
I most beginners never study end games
so it's always so fun to see them during
pogchamps because most of the end game
rules are never followed and you just
see people making stuff up
I know they just do whatever they want
but yesterday we saw Jarvis clutched by
moving his King up and then nada
not just this Pawn now G4 here would be
would be lethal
absolutely lethal because
the H Pawn just goes uh daily dose of
doveretsky that would be cool but yeah
look at look at him look at him go he's
just he's going for it and daily dose
has no pawn moves which could just lose
him the game outright that he can't well
he's going with the King but he knows
that he needs to activate his King in
the end game that's a good sign I don't
know if he knows or it's just because
there's no other moves but regardless
it's good
Alexandra it's going to be king C5 King
C4 King B3 Bishop E6 Checkmate like you
have to play Rook C4 Bishop you're going
to walk your king he on The Rook
and he saw no this is painful oh I feel
bad
oh dailies such a tough day
he is
Levy The Rock no no that was not a
sacrifice that he he just lost we don't
we don't yell for that one and
oh he just resigns and and he's gone
he just resigned and he's gone and
sapnab celebrating
he just lost it feels bad man
oh he just resigns and and he's gone
he just resigned he's gone and sapnap
himself I'm hearing myself yeah
congrats what happened we we saw that
you we saw that you went oh it's back to
the scoreboard he doesn't well yeah well
that was uh
a two nothing yeah a two nothing sapnap
told me yesterday uh that uh that he he
was gonna grind and he was uh and and he
wanted to right the wrongs of his matcha
versus Gastly and this is the group of
death and anything can happen and sapnap
with a resounding two to nothing win
was a back and forth Affair which
definitely reflects the ratings
and one was just an opening surprise
gone absolutely right uh what a match
right I mean that was fun it was fun and
I've been continuously impressed with
sabnab's chess progress so I I mean he
did play these games very well that
being said I do feel bad for daily dose
of Internet it feels like shortest check
hide for shortest Checkmate in pogchamp
history and then going into a game where
he's better in blundering pieces I think
he's just having an off day
yeah for sure this wasn't I mean he he
fought back in this game to his credit
but yeah some something was definitely a
little bit off like um and I I was
actually really worried this would
happen to Jarvis because Jarvis had a
really good showing his first time out
uh versus Frank
and then uh and and then I thought it
was like gonna it was just gonna go you
know revert or something versus Sea Dog
but he beat Sea Dog but that does happen
sometimes you show up and you play great
sometimes you play poorly but after that
open yeah after the first game it can be
tough to bounce back but
um that's that right that's life let's
take a look at other group standings
sapnap gets a very much needed three
points he has one more matchup versus a
guy that is like the sleeping Dragon of
the group his rating is the same rating
apparently as both some of these guys
combined uh and he hasn't played a match
yet yeah his he's allegedly like 1300
yeah no uh virtual is supposed to be one
of the favorites for this entire thing
right yeah yeah so obviously it's way
over performing his rating as well so
yeah no this this group is terrifying uh
yeah yeah gastly's playing like a 1200
uh virtual we don't even know how good
he is and he he has a coach live in
Norway like Anna Kremlin is coaching the
Met like this man is being trained like
a world championship Camp so
I don't know what's gonna happen uh
we're gonna try to get an interview uh
with the winner if we can't then we'll
just keep on rolling pogchamps five
coverage will resume momentarily we'll
be right back don't go anywhere
[Music]
oh
and faustive wow beats the two pieces
with the Rook Aaron made a huge
investment giving up his Queen for Turks
black ones are still quite fast I
literally have no idea what's going on
oh no he's about to lose on time will
you resign now oh Patrick's still
doesn't pass it please
foreign
click the Subscribe button see if it
says subscribe free and purple and if it
does you're golden Ponyboy anyway let's
check on who's priming right now
oh it's my friend
[Music]
um
Willis hey Willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity
flip
anyway back to the chess content you
guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
three two one
[Music]
three two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
you know
come on
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
yourself
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps five uh we are looking at
that's that was a bit trippy I thought
we were yeah we're looking at uh some of
the moments of the match that just
concluded uh between sapnap and daily
dose of Internet it was a it was a tale
of two games and that's kind of been the
case we're lucky enough to be joined uh
Now by sapnap sapnap what's up man uh hi
big congrats on the win today we didn't
have a chance to chat with you yesterday
so I just want to know your impressions
of both matches how how did you feel
after the match yesterday uh was it
exhausting was it relieving frustrating
um it was frustrating because I just
threw away the first game and then I
should have won the the third the first
tiebreaker we played so I just
I just felt frustrated because I felt
like I should have won but it was it was
really close I mean I feel like we have
this is the strongest Group by far so
yeah your group is definitely the most
difficult but on the bright side you won
2-0 today and you got one of the fastest
checkmates in pogchamp's history how do
you feel about it
um I was kind of surprised it happened I
was like I was sent oh I heard that
daily plays the bird and I was sent to
Gambit against it and at first he wasn't
playing into it and then I don't know he
just pushed that pawn and I was like
wait I think I can Checkmate him here
and it worked out so I was very
pleased with pleased with that happening
I guess
yeah G5 was crazy uh we did not know
what you were going to do uh after he
came back with the Knight and I was like
I was just gonna be a Gambit but you
know it's going to be a pawn down for
black and yeah G5 was crazy he reacted
and you didn't even see it at first
right like you were you were pushing
your pond and Alexandra was yelling like
oh my God he's gonna push the pawn but
you took a second and then you uh you
saw it you just like took a step back
and puzzles uh puzzles in a real game
yeah I think that's like my biggest
thing is I just need to like take a step
back and like just assess the board like
I just get too excited when I think I
see something and I just do it and a lot
of times I just blunder away pieces but
I think if I take a step back and chill
I can win most these games so
our tournament formats do you think
that's been helpful
um yeah I think playing in tournaments
like this with a similar format is
always helpful uh the first game I
played though I was actually very very
nervous and I just started blundering
pieces and I had like I'd like reset
like mentally I was like I'm just
blundering everything I threw in my
queen I threw away like I threw away a
piece and then a queen and then I was
just like oh my God like what am I doing
and I just had to like I just resigned
the game I was like I'm just gonna lose
I just need like mental reset and then
keep going from there
well you have a matchup coming up
and that's actually a guy that hasn't
played any games in your group so what
are the emotions going into playing the
mysterious virtual who people are
alleging is is 12 13 and he's like the
Bigfoot of the tournament uh any
thoughts you feeling confident I know
you'll do a little boxing you know maybe
you want to test it out on him how are
we feeling into that matchup if I lose
to him
I need he has to lose two games right
for me to get through so if I lose to
him I'm pretty much out right like
that's kind of how it is I need to beat
him to get through otherwise you have to
or or he has to lose two games to he's
lose a daily dose and Gastly which seems
unlikely I guess if he's that good so
um well hey I have to beat him now he's
not found you can do it again yeah if I
want if I want to win the whole thing I
have to beat this guy eventually so I
might as well do it now
all right well that's
that's got it
um what would you say your odds are
going into the match I know you feel
like you have to do it but you feel like
you're the underdog or do you think
maybe I have no idea I have no idea to
be honest I need to see him play do I
play before him or does he play before
me
I hope he plays before me so I can see
him play yeah I did the math mentally
you need at least a point so you got to
take him to a tie break because if he
Stomps the group but you get a point
then you and gasly are tied with five
and then I don't even know how all that
works because you obviously want to go
to Champions bracket I I'm you know yeah
Champion so you played in events like
this yeah uh what are the nerves like in
this one versus blockchamps or I think
that was the one that you played you've
played in multiple chests so this one
this one's more prestigious so I guess
it's just no offense to block Champs but
everyone wants to win
um you just want POG Champs is like I
feel like it's one of the coolest chess
tournaments there is so it's a there's
more pressure for this one than there is
for like blockchains even though
blockchains was awesome and I loved it
it's great to hear uh we're super
excited to have you here for an
interview we wanted to chat with you
after the matchup versus Gastly that
might be the most exciting matchup but
now you have like two records you
probably will set the record for the
fastest win in this event unless
somebody does it faster and you also had
like a barn burner double overtime yeah
right and everybody loves double triple
overtime uh basketball games so uh
congrats on the big win today hopefully
you can get some rest and then uh get
some sparring in before the uh the big
match versus virtual thanks for joining
us thank you bye
see what's happening
we've got uh we're panning out now to
the uh the groups we see an updated
score there in Group B I'm still calling
this the group of death like the weakest
player in this group averages around 7
800 skill level which is just which is
just saying yeah it's so brutal like how
did they not Shuffle this around virtue
they got like a 1400 an hour he's like
2100 at this rate uh gasly still up top
though Gastly still won both matches
that he's played in uh and uh nobody's
perfect nobody's perfect thus far so
uh wow
that was that was fun yeah fun no I I
enjoy the games I mean are we also going
to be talking with daily dose soon
because I am still very curious what
might have happened today yeah actually
he's uh he's awesome he's still joining
us uh in in it's really great when
players join us in Victory or defeat
like I if I lose a chess match I don't
want to talk to anybody if somebody
wanted to interview I would never do it
so I have a lot of respect uh for folks
that like join winner win or lose and
we're gonna have a chance to speak with
him uh in a moment but first let me tell
you about some twitch drops don't miss
your chance to cash in on shells.com
Twitch drops you can earn two weeks of a
diamond membership by watching two or
more hours with participating streamers
on Twitch you must connect your Twitch
and trust.com accounts to claim the
reward drops will only be available for
a limited time so don't miss it use
command drops in chat to learn
how
um I'm getting in on this I I'm typing
you know when I read this when I read
this uh thing I I'm kind of like shocked
nobody are you involved in this when it
says participating streamers
well that's what I was thinking too I
was a little bit offended where's my
invite yeah I don't know I know now I
feel bad at me I I I'm reading this like
what participating streamers they didn't
ask me anything maybe maybe they meant
the players I don't know but I'm kind of
sad now but listen two weeks
two two weeks of a diamond membership is
nice uh my friends we're gonna we're
gonna be right back we're gonna take a
very short break and we're going to get
uh another interview for you with daily
dose of Internet don't go anywhere
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Champs 5 before we get our second
interview of this match underway just a
few reaction shots from this match
between uh daily dose of Internet
and sapnap and um that was from that was
from game one first of all uh daily dose
welcome to the show thanks so much for
joining uh win or lose
how channels 5 been for you so far
miserable I
um absolutely miserable man you know the
things that like I I'm a very I'm a big
competitor and it just thinks because
like
oh yeah I I know I can play better and
in that second game I I had it you know
and then I just I think I just play too
fast sometimes
no I think it was also really hard to
recover after the first game everybody
gets tilted and I know that you're a
better chess player than what happened
today is there anything you think you
could do to just kind of
feel better about this game after and
then come in with a fresh start for your
next match
I don't know I'm so mad right now like
I'm so competitive
um so yeah I mean like I don't know uh I
just I I know I can play chess very well
and I just made a bunch of dumb mistakes
like I have my Bishop like my Bishop
never moved my Bishop was completely
stuck in a backfield and I was trying
everything I could to get the bishop out
of there and just couldn't
um so just yeah just brushing I made
like two really dumb mistakes and
um yeah but
uh I did not prepare at all for this I I
wish I had the time but I've been
traveling in Norway and everything and
um so I it's funny because like Ludwig
he's like hey you want to participate in
longchamps I'm like cool and then and I
was like never given dates so I just
kind of popped up I was like oh I guess
so uh it's I mean it's not a big deal
but just like I'm not blaming it on
anyone but like it's just frustrating
because like I I know I'm better than
this
well you know recently we we saw uh
Magnus Carlson playing in the bullet
Chess Championship on chess.com and he
was playing in Barcelona while he was
probably drinking and going to a concert
he didn't play that great he was not in
his home element so he got back to his
home studio he immediately upped his
level it's actually all Ludwig's fault
he should have just told you the dates
in advance and it you know it would have
been in your home setup and you would
you would have just been undefeated
I think I would have been you know
professional thing to do but it's okay
well why don't we focus a little bit on
the bright side
too all right give us like a happy
memory there
uh it's always been awesome it's been
crazy it's just a beautiful country
super clean the sunsets are amazing so
like the sunsets last like two and a
half hours I don't know it's just wild
um and this the sun doesn't even set
fully here it's uh so you can't even see
the stars at night because it's still a
little bit of Twilight but it's just
been so much fun and
um yeah I just had some amazing tour
guides uh show me where to go
I
I've I want to ask you a feature chat
question but also the chess coach in me
uh and forgive me from overstepping I do
just want to say like you've played four
games and I've commentated them and
sometimes the result completely does not
reflect the quality of the games and
watching your matchup versus Gastly
Gastly has been in two Wars and he's
emerged with five points out of six but
I'm sure you know you're a competitor
like that match could have gone totally
either way and the same in the second
game against sapnap so I know it's
frustrating I know it's discouraging and
that it the words might also be empty
I've been there like you play your part
out and you you don't have anything to
show for it but you have one more match
and even if you don't win that match you
have the you can just obliterate the
consolation Brad yeah all right take it
out on the on the losers all right so uh
I I think there's still plenty of Hope
and I saw your chest first Gastly and it
was really really good
um yeah yeah it was definitely more it
was definitely more competitive versus
him it's just that that first game uh
with Sam man I was not awake I was just
like whoa like that kind of like woke me
up I should have played like I wish I
should have played a few games or
something before jumping on but it is
what it is
well hey sounds like you could do that
in the next game
um so you're actually in the same
country as a virtual uh does that change
how you feel at all maybe you guys can
do a little something in person
really what cities again
that we don't never mind if we did yeah
if we did maybe we will tell you
privately I don't know if we should send
a crowd of people
isn't he playing in a chess bar right
now so isn't he in Oslo
ah well that well that's that's
tremendous I didn't I don't know yeah
yeah I just opened his stream he is in
the Oslo chess bar right now
um
like a more Unique City
yeah that's like a seven hour drive for
me but it's all right oh
well
um
daily dose has been it's been great uh
everyone's uh either in this case
Alexandra a friend or myself uh a fan I
I don't know you personally but I feel
you know I've watched so much of the of
the videos congratulations on on all the
success all the hard work uh I see all
your you know your your tweets and so on
and and um I'm sorry it hasn't gone your
way so far but hopefully match three
does and if it doesn't you've got always
the consolation bracket to destroy so
thank you for joining us for for an
interview regardless of the results uh
everyone's a big fan and the world
cheering for you
of course thank you you don't want to do
after this I'm just going to watch my
reaction and everything because I
haven't seen that yet I'm just gonna
like cry I'm like oh my god well you
were taking it really well you were
you were supposed
did you get my rage put yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think it was there yes
it was good it was good oh that's why I
was surprised to see you in the
interview I was like oh okay he was
I know I almost turned on the interview
I was like no I had to cool down a
little bit
well we appreciate it and we'll let you
go uh you can watch the highlights you
can get some some good food uh and we'll
see you back for your third match thanks
so much for joining man sounds good
thank you so much bye now
see you
and that was your daily dose of internet
and we've got one more matchup coming to
your way starting very very soon in a
moment here uh we've got I did a thing
versus Papa Plata Alexandra you had you
had some insights into this matchup yeah
I mean Papa Plata does have more
experience playing in the in this type
of tournament as he was a participant in
the first POG Champs
um but from what I've seen from I did a
thing including his lesson with my
sister he is picking up the chess
fundamentals very quickly and I mean I
think he's also a slight writing
favorite that being said I I see that
our chat is being taken over by Germany
so you know the fans might have some
superpower here to motivate Papa Plata
yeah I'm sure there's going to be some
some German memes I remember seeing uh I
remember seeing this a lot in the first
rendition uh of of POG Champs and all I
will say about the German audience is
they are the second they are my second
largest viewing audience like on YouTube
sometimes they're third yeah sometimes
UK overtakes them but Germany was one of
the first countries to offer to publish
my book in the German language so
Germans love chess and what does Latin
shop mean
but let's put on some player cards let's
give you a little bit of background
because this is the first matchup that
we've had in podcast five of Group D
They Were Striking like part of the
writer's Guild and so on and then
finally we could convince them to come
back and play I did a thing he's 8 25
and hopefully he doesn't does a couple
of things on the chessboard over four
and a half million Subs on YouTube very
nice number and this last one was was
weird because
I I think I know who they're talking
about is that Joe Bruin who they're
talking about CCL commissioner Jolie or
I think it is yeah yeah yeah they should
have just said you know because like
full names I I don't Know full name I
know usernames you know like I
frequently have to look up a streamer's
real name because I don't know if I call
them their screen name like I don't call
you both as live but right that'll be
weird yes but some people are just their
username like I did a thing uh speaking
of usernames and and people who are
their usernames Papa Plata and I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly one of
Germany's largest twitch streamers it's
his second pogchamps appearance
and he's played over 900 games on
chess.com which is
a lot I like his photo it looks like
he's about to drop a rap album or
something oh yeah he's looking he's
looking he's looking good yeah I like I
like the there he is there he is on
stream he's probably is he watching the
streams that what's up man
how you doing I don't know any Germans
so I can't even like if it was Spanish I
could like hype him up I don't know I
don't know nothing in German
um have you had German food
uh
when we were
in Germany did we even eat it
not really I haven't had a lot of German
food other than like cheese and pretzels
and meat which I guess is delicious but
not probably the best for the diet what
about you it just sounds it just sounds
like an American's diet you know oh I
love me some bratwurst oh so good
sauerkraut try to eat that oh no
sauerkraut I'm a big cabbage girl I am
Romanian though so it makes sense
I see I didn't realize I didn't realize
Romanians love their cabbage I also like
beer like the Germans made my mom uh
love beer my mom never drank beer and
then there was a German restaurant and
she went she was like I love beer so my
mom drinks beer a lot I went to
Oktoberfest for the first time last year
um and I know it's a little touristy but
the beer there was incredible
beer is good listen Germans you you all
do some stuff right for sure I mean BMW
uh my goodness I I don't know I don't
drive a car do people like BMWs do you
drive uh I do drive and the thing I like
about driving in Germany is there's no
speed limits maybe oh yeah they got the
they got the um yes yeah exactly exactly
oh I I I'm moving I don't drive by the
speed limit right
speed limit not for him not for me no
it's for the other people uh game games
getting underway here in like a minute
or two but we've done a lot of talking
about the this is also an international
matchup right because it's Germany
versus Australia it's like a yeah it's
like a World Cup matchup
yeah and actually we were talking a bit
about Papa Plata but have you ever
watched any of I did a thing's YouTube
video and seen some of the craze they do
yeah yeah I've seen I've seen a few but
I I think of all the participants I know
the least about these two which is funny
like I know a decent okay we have to
talk about match format they play two
rapid games which are 10 minutes and
five second bonus in case you don't know
this uh for one and a half out of two
wins the match or two out of two wins
the match or we will uh go to a tie
break
uh if it's one to one and we had a
string of tie breaks in a row but then
sapnap decided to win in six moves which
was which was pretty legendary
uh and uh yeah he he got the job done
now let's continue to talk about
Australia and uh and and Germany all
right well
um one of my favorite stories from I did
a thing is he was telling this to a
group of creators how
he likes going spearfishing underwater
in Australia and one of the things he
finds fun is hunting these little baby
octopus and then he described how you
find these little baby octopus
underwater and then you crunch into
their little head and that's where their
brain is and then it all just squirms
out I just wanted you to have that image
oh my God that's hot
what
yeah I know I mean it was pretty
terrifying
um but also kind of kind of hilarious to
picture people doing that
dude I like don't even go into tropical
water I'm just afraid of them stinging
me I don't even
oh my goodness
well
that see this is why these creators have
this many views and why they don't rely
on Netflix shows to popularize the thing
they do like we did but I would love to
go into water somewhere and
bite a jelly it was octopus not a
jellyfish it was an octopus it was an
octopus fake story unless it's on
YouTube well I
ice was a real story and they've done
some crazy
um it's always him and his friend Alexa
they do videos together and in a recent
one they did they were going out to
these coconut crabs and they're these
giant crabs and they wanted to see if
the crab could break a human finger so
they built out a robotic finger to test
it but that didn't work well so then he
paid his friend Alexa to use his own
finger and if you want to see what
happened you're going to have to watch
the video uh-huh
uh-huh Levy's getting more and more
nervous no no I'm I'm pulling it up on
the second monitor here but I have been
instructed to let you all know uh what's
coming up on Monday by the way uh we are
having some uh we're having some more
well sorry mud crabs mud crabs mud crabs
yes indeed it sounds equally as
terrifying on Monday because we give you
the weekend off to spend time with your
family and wonder why there is no POG
Champs coverage we'll be getting started
on Monday with the massive massive top
two
uh uh in uh actually it's not top two
because virtual hasn't played a game I'm
just assuming he's he's top two but he
hasn't actually played yet virtual is
going to play his first match in group b
and it's going to be against sapnap
who's currently in second place and
after that we're gonna see squeak's take
on tyler1
and
I I'm I'm going to await to see if
tyler1 challenges me to another ten
thousand dollar chess match wait he did
what happened
well I was explaining to the audience
that he played quite well
uh and I thought he had very good
chances in his group but he should
fine-tune a couple of things and then he
would be really really strong but I said
many positive things unfortunately he
paused it when I said the negative thing
and said who am I and he would smoke me
in a match one-on-one for ten thousand
dollars then he said he would probably
also beat hikiru and then he would
probably beat Magnus Carlsen so all
three of us versus tyler1 now then I had
an idea and this is my public offer to
tyler1 I I offered to to visit and I can
also bring the dog because he's very
cute and and I could give him some chess
lessons in person he could teach me how
to not be a noodle like he would teach
me to bench press and I thought you know
it's good it's like nerd and and and and
you know and then Jack and we just you
know we just do the thing but I I could
also just play him
that would also be fine with me no I
think that would be a fun collab I'd
like to see it you teach him chess and
he teaches you weights yeah yeah uh he
he is he is very very muscular I'm just
going like that's
he's so strong he he he's your chest box
like oh my God he would kill it and the
crowd would go wild but actually I'm not
gonna say I'm not gonna comment on
height
why is he giant or I don't want to get
paused and challenged a ten thousand
dollar chess match Levy okay that's your
job I see I see okay makes sense
well I uh we have a game that's starting
in a moment
uh I did a thing
pop-up Lata
and
they are looking they're they're looking
ready to go this is our first
I think this is our first truly
International matchup
neither player is a us-based creator
that doesn't count hey hey all right
Chad who are you cheering for Australia
or Germany actually I don't know why I'm
getting the Germans started again what
am I thinking
did it worked so well last time
oh sorry
yeah I would they haven't started the
game yet right I don't
oh
well they're definitely
all right apparently they have started
their game just not on my own oh it's a
it's a Vienna okay okay
can you translate that for me lovey no
no no no no no no
no
I can't
[Music]
we are seeing a lot of similar openings
um although I like that there's there's
a Pawn on A3
whoa that's a cool animation
yeah he's got the he's got the oh oh the
board is up hey shout out to the tech
Team all right we've got a totally
symmetrical position
not oh why not exactly I mean six and
castles but uh so it's 7 40 versus wait
they're
who is Papa plot this playing Black
right
oh I see yeah papa plot is plain black
yes yes yes the chat can't see this but
on my side they're both named papa plaza
I was very confused the chat has no idea
because it just looks pretty but behind
the scenes both pop up both players are
Papa Plata I was very confused okay I
did a thing as playing with white
outstanding I did not understand uh
anyway this is a fantastic move and
that's also a great move and is he gonna
Castle long is the question that would
be exciting we have yet to see a
castling opposite sides honestly we
barely have seen castles today so I
would like that
I know I feel like so many kings have
been left in the center Bishop H4 is
very nice
Bishop page four is nice uh he doesn't
want to trade because he wants to keep
the bishop pair
um are you worried about the pawns on uh
C4 getting doubled after the bishop
trade
no that's way too sophisticated
for me I think I I I'm actually more
worried if white takes oh okay well it's
happening I I'm more worried if white
takes and then this Rook gets open this
is okay this is nothing scary I think
I'm more concerned white is thinking
yeah true you want to just be taking
those as fast as possible saving time
but even though he has the double pawns
now they are helping create a night
outpost on D5 and not an actual Outpost
because C6 could still kick in but you
know what let's not even focus anymore
he pushed go I was hoping for a sack
yeah why did the computer hate that so
much uh oh we just wanted to sacrifice
yes ah the Queen the Queen the Queen the
Queen the queen that's that's why Knight
takes G5 you don't want to push pawns
like this where you've castled uh but
I'm worried that another guy is gonna
call me up for a ten thousand dollar
match so I'm just gonna say it was a
good move
uh and the reason this guy eats
octopuses so you gotta be careful
no it's actually it's Papa platter yeah
the names the names yeah he might also I
I don't know
octopus octopi yeah octopi A3 nothing
scary about this move gotta be careful
with these night Ventures
got to be a little careful because if
the Knight can't actually go forward
it's gonna go back oh that's a
professional move King to B1 wow
your stands just mentals very quickly
has he been doing lessons with y'all or
Andreas she did he did a lesson with
Andrea yeah
how did y'all meet if he's in Australia
he was at Creator Clash when my sister
was also fighting
oh yeah oh and actually oh you know what
I'll share this in between the break but
um him and Alexa once stayed at our
content house at the same time as the
chess bras and everyone went to sleep
and those guys just became the best of
friends and stayed up until like 6 a.m
so you know there may have been some
secret exchange of Chess knowledge there
oh I see oh that sounds like tremendous
fun I like to stay up until 6 a.m and
exchange chess knowledge that's that's
wonderful
um by the way Papa Plata is just no
respect for the king I mean the king
bought a house and proceeded to to shoot
a bazooka into the roof and and there is
just this is all open and and it's
raining and it's gonna rain a lot and
very quickly I mean Rook H4 removes the
night even Knight H2 removes the A3 okay
Queen H6 just not right now
yeah A3 works I mean he could kick out
the night at any point it wasn't really
necessary but maybe he feels like he
wants to make sure there's no attack on
his King before he starts to make an
attack on the opposite King
oh my God Papa platter looks so angry he
looks so intense I love it
he's got to spin the wheel maybe the
wheel will give him oh my God he found
Rook H4
Aussie Aussie Aussie Rook H4 he found it
and the Knight is no longer going to be
able to defend the pawn which means
Queen H6 is just made like it's over if
he goes here
yeah he he's playing this extremely well
um what other options could he try I
mean H5 he would just be giving away a
free Pawn
um
yeah maybe even sacking the Knight and
playing a move like rookie 8 just to get
his King to safety but that's very hard
to see yeah you might need to defend
yourself with something like a queen
move but this this is this is from bad
to worse it's
you just have nothing
and that is why moves like G5 are so
dangerous even if it doesn't result in
an immediate punishment just
six seven moves later hey it's good to
know that you can still agree with
stockfish
I mean at this stockfish we shouldn't
even can I you know you know what I'm
gonna Rebel I'm turning this off
it's it's not nice that an AI gets to
want
to play and it's it's just not fair it's
like if if an adult like was in a
classroom of six-year-olds and made fun
of them I mean it's just not
it's not nice my Elementary School
experience was it not yours whoa and
he's doubling he didn't he did that in
like two seconds putting pressure
towards H6 and yeah if it was turned to
move his turn to move here he could sack
although I guess F5 uh would be a
nice way to defend F5 I mean we'll see
how clutch he is uh because both
sacrifices are good there there we would
yell The Rook but it's kind of like a
baby sacrifice it's nothing epic so you
know we go here Queen H6 we would
quietly whisper uh Rook G4 Queen H6 is a
knockout Rook H6 is hoping that gets
taken but it's not Checkers this this
right here we could yell yeah he plays
Rook takes G4 Queen H6 that that
yeah let's see okay it might be it guys
it might be another sacrifice The Rook
moment but only if it's deserved
only if it's deserved
let's see uh not quite but if
yeah I mean it's still good in fact it's
still good because the only move is Rook
G8 and then the king just dips he's just
like yeah I'm out yeah like the
SpongeBob Meme yeah oh Queen H6 on the
way and I did a thing is about to do a
thing to this black king oh my goodness
King to G8
he's hyped up let's go to the stream
real quick
let's pop in and see and see what's
going on I got a long time to think
about it I've got seven minutes to think
about it
if I go there I don't think you can move
anywhere I don't think he can move
anywhere
I don't think you can move anywhere
this would be cold around here yeah
and then if you can't do this The Queen
Is Not Taken they're still sweet
disrespectful this feels too it's
actually hilarious he has three
checkmates in one move drag out the game
I'm gonna have to do it
and he's done it
[Music]
he's a precaution push paid off okay let
me do no
uh
I did a thing
does the thing indeed takes a one to
nothing lead versus the German streaming
sensation Papa Plata and that was a
clean game from start to finish almost
cleaner than eating a mud crab straight
out of the water with your bare teeth
Oh I thought it was a mud crab yeah yeah
that was a different thing don't worry
there are a lot of sea creatures I'd get
confused too
um but yeah I mean it felt like Papa
Plata made that one mistake opening up
his King and then he was just never able
to recover and I did a thing just played
way too well
I did this is probably why we didn't get
Group D going because they would just
make everybody else feel bad I mean that
was that was Demolition I think the game
review somebody run a game review on
that game because I think White's
estimated ELO was going to be like 1400
I mean he played
he played really really really well that
was a great showing and I don't know
much about the players in group d
uh in terms of Chess I mean Cutie's
there but she yep I was gonna say I mean
cutie has played POG Champs a few times
now
um we have seen her studying chess she
has been getting better and better
um but she
it's also easy to get rusty in between
these tournaments
I have been informed that I did a things
username on chess.com is Papa Plata
stinks oh that's why we were confused
he changed his username to Trash Talk
his opponent is he gonna change his
username every single match that would
be pretty epic can you even change it
that many times or do they freeze you
oh you can only change it once so it's
just gonna be that forever
that's that's absurd that is some
psychological warfare on a different
level can you imagine staring at that if
your opponents were just like Alex
bottas sucks you're just like what like
what did I do to you
I respect it the trash talk and the
psychology is part of the game but maybe
Papa Plato will get his revenge
okay so the second game has started yes
we have a typical POG Champs beginner
special this is the most popular
position after two moves in the beginner
database I think this position has been
reached like 70 million times it it's
it's actually insane Knight C3 is
obviously taking us somewhere else
there's the Italian there's this uh but
but the position that we just had with
Knight F3 Knight C6
is the most popular which is why y'all
should play the Vienna we saw the Vienna
do some crazy stuff today multiple times
but this is four nights
does Lucy ever get jealous of the Vienna
she plays the Vienna oh wow she's like
1100 Lucy oh that's pretty sick we
should have had Lucy in fog gems I mean
but she has a real job and things yes
yes she she yes she provides the health
insurance for the household i i i i yeah
we're not we're not doing that but oh
she would she'd be great she'd be great
in this event I what are these
mysterious H6 moves
that's that's my question I like it he's
avoiding the pin it is oh
sorry my lights were flickering randomly
um okay we got another very symmetrical
position and it looks like they're
playing the same thing but with sides
reversed
yep
uh Papa Plata is gonna play this I think
because that's what he did last time but
with black so I would imagine
I would imagine he's going to do the
same maybe he does the saikuno special
that's a great move and I basically feel
like I did a thing just understands the
symmetrical position slightly better
than his opponent that's just what's
happening and I mean his Pawn push push
might end up being more annoying
annoying whereas a3b4 does get space on
the queen side it does bring the bishop
back
um but then it kind of ends there
one funny thing uh this happened in the
cycuno Frank game and Frank took and
saikuno took the pawn and then Frank
went here but that's ages ago and people
in the chat don't even remember what
they ate for breakfast and the colors
were reversed but yeah yeah you're right
but that's what Frank did he went here
and then he pinned but in this case we
have Queen takes so that was a mistake
he obviously shouldn't have traded off
his Bishop yet he could have oh actually
never mind the pawn was on H3 what am I
talking about up
he's got to go back Queen d1's the only
move will he find that or will he go
here
big question
the accuracy of the players after 10
moves 95 and a half for white 93.1 for
black
the best game of POG Champs literally
ever
so far yeah except maybe sat nav's game
except maybe Sat Nav probably played 100
accurate although I don't think G5 was
accurate in sapnoxious but
we played perfectly it was perfect game
I see
exactly like coach Drew it up not really
but you know
um well Papa Plata has taken his time
here
um that makes me feel yeah okay so he
saw he sees it he plays Queen D1 but now
black slide on D4 is going to be quite
annoying
um he's going to continue looking at C2
and unless he plays a move like 92 to
try to get him out of the center it's
gonna be hard to kick him up
Let's uh
let's check in on I did a thing see how
he's feeling about his position and his
one to nothing lead in the match
trying to distract me
oh the camera's on me and I'm well I've
said stop trying to distract me
okay okay well I think I know what I'm
doing and I like it
I like it I don't think he's got
anything Papa plot there you got nothing
the people in the room yelling I could
even just pushing yeah I think it's his
roommate and friends the crab guy
although nickname but the guy who this
is his finger I caught a um I caught a
funnel web spider this morning it's the
most dangerous spider in Australia
that's so cool did you know you could be
a professional spider hunter in
Australia
Force
this is why Alexander volkanovsky is
going to go down as the greatest fighter
of all time because like Australians are
built differently
that's true I could Castle
just another regular day
yeah you just showed us that he said it
was the blank something uh most uh
something in Australia spider what was
it the most the most dangerous that's
what he said yeah
and uh wow I guess he just caught it and
kept it in a jar for fun because what
else do you do with your time in
Australia other than win at chess I
guess
he's playing at 96 right now and if he
plays A4 C3 A5 like it's just it's just
an avalanche uh for Papa Plata uh I mean
he's playing oh oh my God oh my he about
he's this he's getting revenge for the
spider that's what he's doing
though he does look a little nervous
because he's doing the right plan you
think when's the last time Papa plate
caught a spider
I don't know I feel like I'm in Germany
in the summertime they're they're
definitely going to be out there but
otherwise it feels a little cold
yeah that's fair I I really want to go
to Australia speaking of which it's
it's a fascinating place
all right so here you're showing the
arrows the pawn skin can just continue
marching
um the computer really likes Papa
Plata's position but as Levy said we
don't care about yeah I'm not going to
commentate on all your arrows you crazy
man
yeah yeah I just want that but I figured
that you know after we could go here
here we could go take some takes and
takes and takes and takes and takes
takes takes yeah
Etc that that would be quite nice but he
has to play A4 I mean he might play I
don't know G4 again and
that would not be any good it seems like
he learned his lesson he's keeping the
pawns tight to his King he's taking his
time he's slowing down a little bit
okay I don't love that move because I'm
worried he's gonna open up the G file
and he's gonna go Queen F3 Queen F6 it's
gonna go here here here here here here
and then it's gonna be made it's it I'm
up it's about to be this this okay the
same concept this this but then there's
Bishop V6 then there's a check so he's
going for this pawn and not this Pawn
which means when he takes this Pawn he
can play Bishop here and
so I don't know still some chances for
white
I I do wish she would have continued
attacking on the queen side here because
it seems like he was getting close to
that plan
um and even if You Were Somehow able to
trade F7 and F6 you still don't want to
open up the files looking towards your
king
but you know he's going for the
rudimentary he's just attacking Pawns
this is a great Pawn to win too because
you're going to trade off Black's Queen
if you just took on F6 you wouldn't
actually be doing that but uh I did a
thing could go Rook H7 Rook G7 guard his
Pawn Yeah and then that would be awesome
and then double up I think Rook H7 is
the top computer move yeah it is
even oh wait is he the one who's oh for
a second I thought he was arrowing it uh
because your arrow went over his light
overlay but that's all right all right
ruchiate has been played so now Queen F7
is a great move yep and uh after Queen
H3 there's Bishop E6 check massive
counter attack but if he doesn't play
that and instead he goes oh I'm getting
threatened okay Bishop F7 I don't love
but at least everything is defended now
Rook G5 oh nope that gives away a bishop
look at that I mean a rook he could take
it with the bishop it's been a long day
I don't know the names of pieces anymore
you're doing great love you yeah Rook G7
um and then luckily for Papa Plata he's
still controlling the GH Square so I did
a thing won't be able to just double up
his Rooks
he does get it with tempo
well you know what could happen Rook
here Bishop here Rook here thinking you
have an attack and then Bishop F5 like
he could go here and here and that's
very bad
that's a big oops
instead he goes back to f8 so he's no
longer on the semi-open file
um but he is still kicking the bishop
out of F7
do you think Papa Plato's gonna end up
taking on H6
for sure because he's gonna see that
yeah and then he's gonna be like I'm
winning a lot of Pawns
uh and uh
maybe Knight E7 now maybe maybe I did a
thing realizes that the bishop is a bit
annoying so he wants to get rid of it or
he'll just go F5 because I don't know
he's Australian and he does what he
wants
and once again we have him castling on
the opposite side of Papa Plata what we
have seen so far is it's mostly been I
did a thing that has been attacking the
king uh so we'll see if that changes
since you know there's oh he went for it
he went for F5 he just likes pushing his
Pawn
yep don't hate that move at all nope
don't hate it now Rook takes don't want
to trade queens that not only is trading
Queens bad because you're down material
it also just straight up loses a rook at
the end so
you gotta go Rook F5 uh should we check
in on uh I did a thing yeah let's do it
we're gonna see what
lucky I feel like if we watch long
enough
or insects I should open up another
Square to escape from uh
on that side at least and I can bring my
horse out now
he's got to move Queen if he just he
just just eat that pawn there bro yeah
thank you
you eat the porn
okay so he was almost
I could I guess he understands that he
needs to be going for the the king
attack here and he also saw that he
can't move his Rook for G8
oh wait do I have a pinned
piece up there right on time
oh oh no
why did he play it anyway what a
ridiculous thing that I didn't notice
earlier I'm gonna pretend that was on
purpose I'm gonna pretend that was on
purpose I thought he was talking about
Bishop E6
too I mean it good
yeah yeah I I got real confused there
yeah he thinks this is brilliant you
know there's the players that think they
don't know what they're doing but
they're doing something great
and then there's there's this and this
is the latter this is
you're gonna get one more check but then
the king is gonna go back but maybe you
know maybe he's gonna go here and he's
gonna win I don't know anything about
Chess this is pot Champs
yeah and uh queen of five he's still
gonna have the bishop E6 threat losing a
queen so hopefully he sees that
who knows yeah bring on a boat to
scambit says Jason well we haven't seen
one yet today
there we go Queen goes to F5 maybe he's
gonna you know he's gonna go here that's
check by the way so
um
all of this might be possible
I think we're okay okay
well now he doesn't have to worry about
the E6 Fork anymore
but he is down material
Queen takes D3
maybe we bring the queen back Queen T3
is a great move because then you start
feasting and this gets very scary for
white so
let's
remember Chad if we take anything away
from today it's when you're up material
and you want to have an easy life just
trade off your pieces simplify it'll
help
oh what's Papa Plato reaching out for
what where's he going we just lost we
just lost our German streamer oh there
he is
what's he doing what is that you're
getting more candy I think that's what
it was earlier
oh his mouse battery died oh that's so
that's that's bad yep okay B6 don't love
this move uh because now it's weakening
the light squares on the king side and
yes the bishop is pinned now he also
didn't see the pawn on D3 but now the
Knight is actually under attack so maybe
Papa Plata is finally getting his
revenge
King E2 was brilliant by the way because
it sets up this and that
yeah which tough tough defense
that's crazy
that is a crazy move
the computer is trying to oh oh
chess Gambit
oh Bishop G4 Moment of Truth look for
maximum danger
I looked at the arrows on Papa Plata
stream and when he moved King E2 he only
saw the Knight but that might change now
he hasn't seen it yet though he's
looking at Bishop G5 right now uh oh I
mean wait he slowed down he slowed down
uh
Moment of Truth okay but he can get it
on the next move because rookie 8 is
going to be played and then Bishop G4
again
ah or Bishop E4 and then Rook F1
something like that yeah I mean
regardless this position looks very good
for white and he's up a minute on the
clock
there's also all sorts of like back rank
problems when Queen and shade the king
can't actually come off so he's gonna
have to go here
so
I think I think this move is going to
happen I think he's gonna find it
and regardless he has definitely played
this game much better than the first
even though his King is once again out
in the open this time it was for good
reason
oh this King I mean yeah the the white
king is is having a great time the black
king is uh
okay you were right Levy the predictor
rookie eight yeah I understand the The
Human Condition as it pertains to being
below 1200 you know
all right Bishop G4 like taking is a
completely good move because you just
give away the bishop for the Knight
and then maybe Queen h8 and then the
king comes up and then as the king gets
closer to the queen you go oh wait I had
Bishop G4 but let's see
let's see
even know what is going on with Bishop
to G4
I did a thing looks like he's
here but he's fighting through it
there's also some like Bishop takes and
then Bishop C6 and the king is stuck on
the back rank that's another way to put
a Checkmate net I think we're gonna pop
in on I did of things uh his camera at
least we don't have his live stream I
don't believe he's streaming so I'm
gonna draw arrows here see this is me
drawing the arrows so you see that point
well why why would you not be thinking
why would you not eat it
why would you not eat that why would you
not H5 is a weird move but I guess he's
attacking The Rook because does he want
to eat and then eat my queen
is that what he wants to do you want to
eat and then eat my queen but you just
kind of gave me the opportunity to
protect it then
I mean I still lose that peace
but
well
why would he not eat that this makes
sabotas Gambit less possible because now
after Bishop G4 you have a blocking
piece
yes it's still very much
the best move it will continue to be the
best move probably for the duration of
the game
uh Rook here there is still Bishop G4
and queen here you know uh that's the
best move but
then maybe Queen check and queen here
okay game on all right
and again to win the match I did a thing
just needs a draw and hey if I was him
in this position I would be
ecstatic to get a draw
yeah yeah I'm not even sure like the
GM's know that right the GMS are like
I'm winning so I just need to draw I'm
good he he's I don't think he's thinking
that either yeah oh what a good move
bringing the only piece that hasn't
moved yet Rook F1 and the G2 Pawn but it
doesn't exist Rook F1 is just
clean Bishop C6 get on the light squares
infiltrate that's what you have to be
thinking of here only bad intentions
yeah he's playing this very well
I feel like we saw a different player
from game one to game two
maybe he just needed a warm-up
yeah
so time is getting pretty low 238 or I
did a thing 342 for Papa Plata
it's going to be wrapping up
pretty soon
C5 is a nice move you got to uh
uh try to open up for the queen there's
no other way for black like the queen
would love to teleport but can't do that
got a long journey there
and right now the queen is playing
defense which is not really what it
should be doing uh I mean it should be
more offensive but there's not much you
can do position is very tough
very very tough I really like even moves
like Bishop G4 with Tempo and then
bringing the Rook to F7 although
you know there's so many good plans here
for white as long as he's thinking about
a plan and where he wants all his pieces
to go he'll find something
yep
I did a thing takes with the d-pawn
which I like he doesn't want to open the
B file that would be pretty dangerous
for his King
but what's White's next move I mean he
it's been 28 moves and white is playing
at 90 accuracy
wow and and someone in the chat said
that they think Papa Plata is nervous
because he normally would have seen the
pin and I'm sure that people are more
nervous in this tournament
um than they would have been just
playing casual games so I think that's
fair
yeah I mean nerves play a huge role you
use completely missed things you
otherwise would have seen Bishop C6 is
kind of a little bit one move style like
Rook is going to go here now and then
he's gonna have to find Rook F7 which is
tough but definitely findable
and then Queen F5 check I can't draw
arrows Queen have five check and so on
but
okay yes had a feeling
Rook F7 two and at two minutes 40
seconds for white he can't keep thinking
for 20 seconds at a time he's gonna
he's gonna flag
I mean it's it's hard to play Bad
positions
hard to play good positions too
it's true they're both gonna run out of
time I mean again white is spending
another 20 seconds
he's spent 30 seconds on this move like
they just don't have it makes me nervous
but I like that he's taking his time I
think it's important
and the worst case he's had he has those
past pawns he could always push them if
he gets too in time trouble it's it's
very easy with two minutes to just be
like oh I know I have to trade Queens
when I'm up and then you do this and
then take and then take and then you
lost your bishop and you're still
winning because the Rook end game two
pawns up these pawns are flying down the
board it's very easy but oh my God I
have a very bad feeling he's gonna go
here but maybe he sees this and he's
gonna move it but this is a very natural
move to play because you trade the
Queens yeah he's been queuing it up but
I I'm sure he's gonna see that he does
under attack it's close enough to his
um there we go Bishop B5 all right love
you know I Gotta Be Afraid Anymore
uh yeah the bishop is completely safe
now also the king is completely safe and
queen E4 and this and and also getting
the rook in but
time is ticking and they are they are
really taking their sweet time to play
this game out I mean it's 125 on the
clock for black
120.
yeah
I think we're gonna listen into the the
German side of things
and chat you can just try
another plan he started pushing his past
pawn and
that's not actually a free Pawn because
if Queen takes H4 you have Queen F7
check yeah
yeah uh Queen here you were right Queen
takes there was Queen F7 and if this
there was mate
none of that was seen by either player
but we're just gonna put it there this
is completely defended this is such a
fortunate position
the queen is hanging will he play Queen
takes Pawn
if oh the clutch defense from Papa Plata
and The Rook is getting into
is playing this incredibly but I did
like E4 as a try for black here
there is still Rook to E5
if white plays I mean it's almost over
by the way Queen E8 is a mate like Queen
eight is threatening mate in a lot of
positions Queen E8 he will go back but
if Queen E7 rookie E5 is a fork
there are traps
although yeah Queen E8 does feel like a
more natural move we know that newer
players love checks you give a check and
you feel good what more do you need
and like always two ways to win a
winning position trade the Queens end
game boom or go for mate uh he's got 120
on the clock this is terrifying
oh my gosh
he he just hovered Rook F1 for a second
yeah I know I it was one second but it
was a very confusing second
time is ticking he is arrowing for Queen
to E8 he might think it's made but then
Queen d8 and then he's got to realize he
did it he can trade and push yes he
could just go here
or this he's trading and he's going to
push his pawn and that's probably the
end of Black's chances it is impossible
to save this with black unless white
stalemates that is it
I see the pop-up comments saying come on
I did a thing it's nice to see you guys
promoting your creators uh he's gonna
need a a lot of help surviving this game
but it's not over
it it I mean it just as well might be as
long as
that okay it he did not realize that he
could have just pushed the pawn and now
the king is off the back Rank and
anything can happen King here King here
oh my goodness the nerves are gonna set
in and the more time that he has to make
a move
does he realized H7
he does wow nice and
nice move is he gonna defend the pawn
defend the pawn and push the Jeep on
he's gonna do it
there it is
G5 okay he's taking the more pawns you
take the higher chance of a stalemate oh
he's lost The Rook but that's a good
thing that's a good thing
he sees it oh my goodness he's got some
pawns remaining hoping for his stalemate
I did a thing just has to run and
there he's got to push the pawn he's got
to get rid of his pawns oh no
you might not know he's trying to chase
the pawn you gotta go the opposite
direction
yeah all you can do here is hope for a
stalemate or hope or Hope For The Rook
to be blundered somehow true king F6
King F6
step back good Jesus oh that's it oh
this is a frozen position now
bring the king
freeze the Pawns
under one minute for Papa Plata oh no
he's behind on the clock he plays D4
yeah the only thing that might happen
here is his nerves it's really hard to
play in time pressure and he knows that
if he somehow doesn't win he loses this
match and as I say that Daniel wrench's
comment pops up Papa's so nervous yeah
no I can tell I mean he's been playing
so well he's just he has nerves you have
to you have to just have a game plan
when you get this deep into the end game
you got to go all right I'm gonna cut
the king off and then I'm gonna get a
second Queen I don't care about any of
this nonsense I just wanna so just like
go here go here but psychologically it's
so hard to let go of this and he's down
to 40 seconds on the clock
oh no
this is trending totally in the wrong
direction 30 seconds on the clock now
he plays all the way back he's going to
lose his pass Pawn anyway he'll make
another one he's got the d-pawn oh yeah
the thing goes towards the f file so he
won't get cut off that's good he's and
white is going into give checks and and
panic mode and now he's going into push
the pawn as fast as possible but the
king is going to get caught
now the king could get caught on the
back rank but King B6 now don't go to
the back rank
back rank A7 King 8 Bishop C6 mate
you gotta go up
oh no check uh oh then I can get
uh-oh okay this is it
Moment of Truth check with the pawn oh
my God please don't go here oh he's
trying to set it up
that's clean that is clean Pawn to C4
try to get a stalemate but he's gonna
move his King he's forgetting about his
Pawn
oh he's done it and but that said he's
gonna Queen him he's making a crazy
season checkmate
oh papa Plata with the defense with the
end game technique A8 Queen promotion
and he gets the job done let's go for a
live look see the last moment of the
game here
boom let's go
oh my god let's go
boom all right
you get it they get it through the
message Chat
begins to get a match
amazing oh my God amazing
one to one the score of the Opening
match in group D and we have our fourth
I'm not gonna keep counting them as we
keep getting them but we've had multiple
tie breakers on multiple days it's one
to one in group D between Papa Plata and
I did a thing both players winning
convincing games with the white pieces
we've been here before this is a
pogchamp special both sides winning with
white yeah yeah everybody just wins with
white that's what they do no you're
right but I think this is one of the
closest tie Breakers that well I mean
it's the closest tiebreaker we've seen
today in terms of their strength
oh for sure and it's really going to
come down to that rule let's let's just
remind everybody speaking of that rule
of the tie break rules uh the the game
that they play now is seven minutes less
than they get for the 10 minutes so it's
three minutes and five seconds bonus
and the players the person the person
the person that plays white is
determined by the accuracy of the
previous games which I think based on
the game that you just saw Papa Plata
played 85 over 58 moves if this man is
not playing with white I don't even know
what to say uh if the matches tied after
this game then they play again they just
switch and we repeat until somebody wins
I did a thing this game was so accurate
yeah I've just been informed that
despite the 85 accuracy of Papa Plata in
the game with white I did a thing was
more accurate and gets white in the
playoff that's crazy
well I did a thing is gonna have to stop
getting distracted by Alexa and by the
spider on his desk
um I will say papa Plata did look a
little bit more uh locked in during
these games uh she looked he looked
locked in he looked uh the game is on by
the way the game is on we have E4 E5 and
we're gonna get the same symmetrical
stuff but
oh or maybe not Queen out we going for
cheese no no cheese lactose intolerant
Knight F3 Bishop C5
there it is look at that
another one of the most common POG
Champs positions
yep
chat don't forget use your type user
Channel points predict who you think is
going to win so that you can get more
free internet points yes
let's do it by the way Papa Plata
blocked in his Bishop not a huge fan of
that don't hate it but
uh it's better than pushing the Pawns in
front of his king that's an improvement
already
and in this game we don't see an early
H3 from I did a thing he's usually
blocking those pins but it seems like
they're going for a very similar game to
the first one with on our opposite side
castling I have never seen a beginner so
cerebral
in in which side he castles like
he castles Queen side all the time to
create attacks this is not even a
blunder by the way because Knight F5 is
a monster attacking move Knight F5 is
winning for white it is winning if he
plays it but four pieces could take and
he doesn't see it and ed4 and papa Plata
is uh is winning now because of the
exchange loss oh goodness it's just too
easy to focus on recapturing the last
piece that your opponent just took
um yeah especially when you have four
pieces I could take it like how could
you not take it right yeah and oh no
this is the famous Boomerang the night
guards this wow
oh he's losing the bishop too oh papa
plotted from the top rope and the PIN
oh my gosh this was just a tumble of bad
events and again this is the first game
where I did a thing didn't play H3 to
stop the pin and look what happened
the only thing that is that is stopping
Black from winning is that he's upper
rook and The Rook is there like Rooks
are end game pieces so if if uh if I did
a thing now just does this with
everything he's got left he might still
save the game so that's it because this
Rook is going to be a long while away
from participating
this is not over but only if white plays
like this
Papa Plata is thinking again
um just don't take don't don't take do
not take right that's we don't want that
you don't want to open up that file
okay we have two I like
back up back up yep now will he do this
bad move because the bishop lives Bishop
is Immortal now wooden Shield here we go
again yeah we've seen this a lot today
sapnap had it not it's not a good move
you don't want to open the center when
you're trying to attack you want to lock
it have as many pawns together as
possible now it takes as good Bishop can
get in there's a five
E6
E6 Works push you're trying to push the
pawn towards the king would also be a
good idea
um Rook F1 I actually don't hate he's
probably seeing that if D takes E5 F
takes E5 he's gonna attack F7
um but now he has to do something to not
lose or trap his Bishop on V3
yeah but he could play F5 F6 oh C3 is
not a bad move at all uh but F5 F6 would
be vicious if black allowed it true
because of all of this
the bishop should stay here
it should not go back this way
and unfortunately they've just played
too fast so nobody's in time travel
right that like you can't rely on the
clock
the reroute
look at this
okay he's doing the right thing
easy move you can just play it quickly
not sure why he's taking his time here
yeah let's see what what I did a thing
is is thinking here down a rook Against
All Odds the monster comeback potential
okay
Let's ignore that push
yep he's going for it oh my goodness
oh my goodness he he might win this game
no he never pushed the wrong one
oh and he might lose the game
oh
six was opening the king he was oh my
goodness he might lose it all that's all
right
he definitely can't eat it F6 was was
right there
and he added Arrow too
wow
yeah let's pull up the analysis board it
now it's over uh I don't see a way for
white here he's still trying he had the
right idea totally wrong execution F6
would have potentially won him the game
with check and mates oh
he was so close
yeah I mean now he's just down way too
much material I mean it it's almost over
he still has some ideas uh he could even
play yeah Bishop B3 get his Bishop on
the long diagonal and start pushing his
other pawns at the end of the day it is
still blitz so they aren't going to be
as accurate as they would with more time
it's true yeah rookie one and black
might accidentally give the bishop and
suddenly white is winning because of
Bishop B3 what was that that was a move
I didn't click that on accident but yeah
Queen and queen B2 is game over does
Papa Plata C the sneaky Queen sneak to
B2 ending the oh
oh
all right Goodness Me we're gonna need
to move like Bishop C2 or queen C4 to
come in with the queen to protect
okay we have checks we have checks we
can go here and take does he see this oh
check the clutch defensive move by by
white
wow now of course black Is Still Moments
away from winning but oh don't go here I
would hide the king you go here and he's
done it you could the only chance white
has now is to get to H7 yeah I mean
there's even a world where he could
sacrifice his work on H7 if his Queen
could get to H5 yes because
King can't go back just
what oh oh he's going for it that is
something that is a ridiculous move Papa
Plata has to play A4 if he gets scared
this is this is insane that is a
question covering over it he's looking
at A4 and now it's just
he's a little bit afraid of Bishop takes
A4 yeah let's go
she probably doesn't see Queen B2 yeah
let's let's see
let's see he he's touching his Bishop
okay I see the move that he played on
the live board we're about to see it
here it's not a good move it doesn't
deal with the situation
Queen C7
I mean C4 like again it's these light
squares versus dark squares right F4 is
not what you want D5 is not what you
want you don't want any of these moves
but he had to play A4 to remove the
blockade but now he doesn't see a way in
but the thing is but I did a thing also
doesn't see the correct plan to attack
his King yet yeah but sometimes you just
gotta keep a little bit of defense and
hope that your opponent gets lower on
the clock uh Papa platter one minute 24
on his clock yep on the current board
not the one we're watching yeah let's
yeah let's go uh let's let's pull it
back here black uh
uh black is is down nearly 40 seconds on
the clock he has played D5 which which
was a free oh my goodness that's mate
Queen takes G7 is Checkmate on the board
Queen E1 does he see the bishop is
hanging Queen to eat that is a
ridiculously sneaky move
I mean
Queenie one
and then
even if he defends his Bishop maybe
trying to reroute it to D1 yeah oh no he
just goes back on this on his cozy
square but a queen oh that's check oh my
goodness I mean but still I don't love
this because you're drawing attention to
the H file but I guess he's doing what
gasly did Gastly tried to get in with
the that's a incredible move now Rook H3
Queen G2 is a fork this might be it this
might be the conclusion of the game is
King B1 the only oh no he has to move
his Rook yeah where does he even move
his rook and and defend it he can't he
can't maybe he goes crazy just
sacrifices the rook and tries to uh but
Queen G2 oh
Queen G2 from papa plaza is vicious and
there it is he's picking up the Rook wow
and that might be it short of him losing
on time yep absolutely
crazy what a clutch play here the queen
rotating
take the rook and that's
losing this game will be impressive Now
by black
hey don't say that don't jinx it
he could bring his Rook he could keep
checking but
he'd honestly need to do something like
a 4 get his
try to sacrifice his
stalemate but even then it seems
unlikely
the king is out here which means make
can't be far away Ponta A4 is brutal the
bishop has to walk into a pin if the
queen leaves it's a discovered check and
probably mate Queen here and here oh and
he's just
and straightforward is is the best plan
ahead yeah especially when you're low on
on the clock just do what's the easiest
way to win oh no need to stress no need
to stress C4 is the only thing that you
could do here with black is somehow by
an insane
turn of events you could still make I
don't even know how
yeah there's
no way yet
so low on pieces it might be on the
horizon
Queen to B7 C4 is a discover check but
you lose the bishop
the only way to lose with black is back
rank mate you would need to lose
literally every piece or at least two of
them
you can just continue with his plan even
if he loses his Bishop he's so ahead
here F3 F2 F1
yeah
it's just nothing I mean there's nothing
you can do okay please Bishop F6 fine
I would go King A4 just for no reason
just want to get out of the PIN
yeah I'm just trying to remove my like
my King's squares that the king could go
to so yeah F3 is yeah
that there's nothing I mean queen F5 is
very sneaky hope that he's pushing and
you just take the queen but yeah just F2
she's gonna go ah he's changing his plan
now
Queen D5 keep the queen and the bishop
looking towards GA just in case both the
Rooks somehow decide to get off the back
rank yeah Queen D5 is the best move
because the Rook might come down and he
might lose this Rook oh 15 seconds for
white by the way did not even realize oh
my gosh
okay goes there he's looking for him
looking to link it for me somehow
F2 I respect
crazy
yeah he there's just there's not much
white can do here no no
he's trying he's got to keep going he's
about to flag five seconds oh and he
made it just in time F1 Queen black is
up a ridiculous amount of material and
queen to see one is just made
momentarily
oh the bishop Bishop E7
okay
this is considered a missed win because
the computer sucks that that's a free
Queen but it
could be stalemate yep
he oh oh my God he's he's a bit lucky he
didn't lose his Queen there
King A4 there's still no Maiden one it
might be Rook B4 King A5 and a mate okay
that's mate okay yep that's mate that's
made in two
clean before
oh he's missed that King goes here now
D3 is discovered check and made Pawn
push
he misses it again oh my goodness could
we be headed for a stalemate Queen D3 I
know it's a free Queen but it no I mean
that's not his best stalemate chance oh
no oh no there are ways here
Pawn takes Queen takes Queen H7 is still
oh
he's not shocking him close so close
Queen A3 and that's it just Queen A3
King A2 Queen to A3
he might he might go here
Queen to A3
only move he's doing it for Content he's
a big streamer he knows what he's doing
it's it's it and and and and white loses
on time
oh he was pre-moving Checkmate okay okay
there you go hey you played with our
emotions just for a second
let's go oh huge let's go indeed
wow boom job
oh my God amazing holy that was
mischief
that was that was incredible what a
match the music is very fitting
celebratory music that was
that was a wild match what a great match
to finish the day on two to one Papa
Plata opens the scoring in group D over
I did a thing one of the craziest
comeback matches first match totally
one-sided and then he followed it up
with a one-sided victory of his own and
a clutch 50 move performance
in the tie break
wow
this was the highest level match of
today
um and we really saw Papa Plata Step It
Up good for him there
oh yeah he I
couldn't be happier for the guy uh
amazing we're obviously gonna try to get
some interviews next
uh
what a day what a day amazing
uh International match up there and
let's take a look at the
at our standings two points for Papa
Plata one of those points is given to I
did a thing for even making it to a uh
tie break and fusely and cutie
Cinderella yet to get on the board but
that's okay because I think many many
players haven't had a chance to play yet
that was fun
it was
um
does that mean that we're bringing them
on soon
I think so I think our plan right now is
we're gonna check in with the players
we're going to hope for an interview uh
but we will be right back with pogchamps
five day three about to wrap up don't go
anywhere
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
I've been using it for a long time I
mean if you look up here I've actually
have my streak it says 1231 days right
you're gonna forget a lot of the things
that are in the book Jessica came around
when I got on adjustable it's literally
I was already doing that so this is now
a game changer because I can do it
faster it's online it's in front of me
all of my books are here if they're
going to be folders now so I can
categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how I use
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
stressable it actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this like success really is just
working on chessable just being honest
with you
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
oh I didn't even realize they started
they started and Charlie busts out the
uh the Dutch
the Dutch defense by Charlie and wait a
second happy pre-moved
yes he has
a tire kingside development
those squares are moved with red have
you noticed Jimmy is making actual moves
have you seen
wow he lets his eyes move the pressure
in my hands
the future in my hands
[Music]
let's go
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps five we're just seeing some
game footage from this last match of the
day here on day number three we see uh
x-rays
we see pins and discovered attacks and
it was a back and forth match that
ultimately was decided boom in the words
of Papa plot versus I did a thing we've
got both of them joining us thank you
both sometimes we do interviews
separately sometimes do them together uh
it was an amazing match I know it it
went one way it went another way it was
back and forth I want to start with uh
the German streaming sensation himself
Papa plot welcome to the show uh I want
to compare your experiences you played
in POG Champs once you're playing into
some years later what's what's your
chess Journey been like
uh I haven't played like for like four
months or something I I casually play on
my phone like
yeah like one or two games a month or
something but not much you know I have
trained for like the chess boxing event
of Ludwig but uh I couldn't
um participate because I had an incident
with the ear
uh but yeah that was the last time I
played chess
are you trying to rub it in you're
trying to rub rub in how little you try
chest no no no that's not the plan man I
was so nervous today
the cool thing is that both of you guys
have done boxing uh would you ever do
chess boxing again maybe a potential
match up here
oh my God
I I would definitely do it but yeah I
guess you would me up man
like ripped and six pack and muscled
holy he he's crazy he in the middle
of the game versus you he picked up a
spider and he's and he like in the thing
in the kitchen container he said I
caught a spider today it's the most
dangerous spider in Australia
Australians are like different people
compared to us like you guys are the
strongest scariest people on the planet
man it's unbelievable it turns out it's
the most dangerous spider in the world
well I was keeping it because I caught
it and then I was like I can't just let
this loose anywhere and I wanted to um
he wasn't looking so good so I was
heating him up with a hairdryer to try
and uh revive him and then that's why I
was that's why I was late for the chess
game so I was like now I just need
to put this spider on my desk I was just
been staring at it all game
it sounds like that spider maybe was a
distraction a little bit yeah it could
have been could have been
uh I I've I've
um
I've I've wondered uh you know the chess
scene in Germany is like really big I'm
not sure if you're aware how big it is
but Germans are are number two number
three for like viewing audience in the
world it's U.S for me personally at
least and then it's very close tied UK
and Germany okay is there a very very
strong chess culture there I mean I know
you don't stream it all the time oh I'm
yeah I'm not sure about it I mean I have
some chess friends
um a German uh chess streamer and stuff
but
um I'm not pretty sure to be honest I
guess it's not that big in Germany like
when it comes to streaming you know so
not not many people are streaming it but
um I don't know to be honest
and I'm not sure but I I I every time I
play chess people really enjoy it so and
every time I participate in this uh
tournament and stuff guys are like uh
the people in the chat are really
enjoying it so yeah but I don't know if
it's so big in Germany I don't know man
but the German community in general is
very like uh active I guess it's a very
strong somehow
well speaking of Chess you guys have
your upcoming matches still with foosli
and cutie Cinderella I'm curious how
you're both feeling about those maybe
we'll start with Papa Plata sorry Papa
Platt
uh it's papa plaza but it's fine it's
fine no problem
yes sorry sorry uh yeah two more matches
yes yes
I'm sorry English isn't my first
language
um yeah um I I guess I I try to train a
bit more and maybe go through the
matches uh we play today with my German
chess friend uh and and coach and try to
improve uh to the next uh match maybe a
bit more and maybe I yeah I was very
nervous today maybe you can reduce that
for the next time
and and the same question goes to uh
mister I did a thing over there I you I
I you were making plans already for
what's after the stream uh and if you
know you're gonna go surfing spearing
it's an incredible lifestyle you live
over there I mean is any of that gonna
be helpful to prepare for the future
games
I think sauna could definitely be
helpful you know clear yet clear your
headspace a little bit and then maybe
spearfishing murdering some animals you
know help me get in that kind of the
kind of bloodlust which might I didn't
actually tell the story
oh yeah I heard that oh that's horrible
I sound like a monster like yeah thank
you oh it's gonna it's gonna be a clip
yeah she really traumatized me with it I
just wasn't prepared she just you know
she just brought it into a chest stream
I didn't even know
uh no judging it was just very left
field I didn't know what to do with that
information no but um but no no I think
it was it was nice playing those games
because it gives me some um perspective
of like of how stress actually impacts
uh the games and I think moves which I
would have clearly seen uh for like in
the in the in the uh the the final one
in the third match just that move where
I just pushed the wrong pawn and
realized afterwards was like if I just
pushed that other pawn it would have
opened something up and there were so
many other opportunities where I just
noticed it later I'm like there's a
there's a fork on the on the queen that
whole time if he moves it down I'm just
like ah it's just it's hard it's hard
but it's fun it's very fun
of course no like both of you played
exceptional we were saying it was the
closest match of the day uh the accuracy
was was super super high uh I know both
players can't win a match so if somebody
has to win somebody has to lose but you
you both got Group D off to a great
start I want to thank you both for for
coming on uh I know it's I actually I
don't know what time it is in Australia
I was gonna say it's late but it's like
14 hours time difference with New York
so if it's later if it's early
okay well enjoy the rest of your day
blah blah I know it's uh very much one
in the morning there so hopefully we can
let you go sleep uh and we'll see you
all back very soon for your next match
bye-bye thank you see you later
bye guys
one last look everybody at the group
standings
we've got finally an update in group d
pop-up Lata takes an early lead with two
points I did a thing
certainly did he played some incredible
chests today with one point on the
scoreboard but there's multiple matches
remaining uh tyler1 is an elite in uh in
group C and groupie had some
shuffling today what a day it's been
I I've missed pogchamps I'm glad it's
back
and uh you know the tournament is still
very early I have no idea who is the
favorite for this thing
oh yeah me neither we we see Frank on
stream delivering a mate today versus
psychuno we've got sapnap a guest
with the uh six move checkmate
off the opening trap and this match was
a barn burner decided ultimately by time
but a very convincing tiebreak win by uh
Papa Plata very fun yeah very fun day of
matches
chat let us know which one your favorite
was for today and uh when is the next
match when can people tune in
we're uh letting people relax for the
weekend or maybe we couldn't Wrangle
enough streamers to compete but I think
it's uh everybody's off on Saturday and
Sunday so yeah let's look ahead to
Monday before we sign off for the day
we're we're really looking forward to
the first matchup on Monday I will not
be covering it uh I uh I get a day off
but the matchup on Monday that we have
coming up is um is going to be virtual
versus sapnap that's a that's a very
very exciting one uh as well as squeaks
and tyler1 we we have a we have a little
card for those but uh I I don't know if
they were gonna put them up but but now
you know regardless so whether we're on
screen or whether they're on screen it's
it's all good so come back Monday chat
yeah come back on Monday that's going to
be at 5 PM Eastern if you don't you're
not gonna remember over the weekend you
all have you all have crazy lives uh
you're gonna find out and uh and and we
have another match on on Monday actually
which is uh which is Jarvis versus
saikuno and uh that that's going to be a
three-match day on Monday
group a finishing up Group B
uh getting underway with virtual we
haven't actually seen him play so we're
about to find out Group B is group of
death for sure I'm very much looking
forward to it
I uh I I had a I had a blast today a lot
of very fun chess Alexandra I don't know
if we know our commentary schedules are
you aware of when you'll be back I am
actually going to be traveling for the
next week so I won't be there
um but I will be there in person for the
live final I hope to see a lot of you
guys there we haven't had a live POG
Champs final before ever so it's gonna
be very very exciting
super excited to look forward a super
exciting thing to look forward to yeah
for sure it's in three weeks exactly on
August the 18th uh but this was a very
fun day so far we've had non-stop chess
action and it will continue over the
weekend you all get some rest we will
get some rest pogchamps 5 will resume on
Monday July the 31st we'll see you then
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is
that's me I'm shaking I'm shaking right
now psychuno forgot about his bishop and
we go there okay that's a Checkmate baby
oh oh wow yeah good job
oh it's on the board
oh my goodness that was a genius
oh I feel bad
[Applause]
Alexa with the end game technique
let's go
[Music]
they're the only move okay there you go
you're afraid with our emotions
oh huge let's go indeed
[Music]
let's go